Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, today I will not forget this time.
I will not, we're gonna, I'm here so we can give up the game
codes for real this time, guys, for real.
All right, let me set this up.
Okay, I didn't forget this time, guys.
I think it was easier if I just do it right off the bat.
So for this, you don't know.
I am a voice actress in the game.
Gold, gold, Adventure Gold is my very first voice acting gig
ever and they gave me three codes to give to three lucky
dragoons and today is the day I remember first off I need to
find the codes I remember all of that but also I might
forgot where I placed the codes so let me see if I could
find it let me see okay um game of code my manager gave it
to me and And I'm trying to remember where it is.
To keep, please.
It's here somewhere.
I know it.
I know it's here somewhere.
I just realized.
I was like, am I missing something?
And I was like, oh, yeah.
Where did I...
Which channel is it?
Which group chat?
What is this?
Don't worry.
I'm scrolling right now.
I'm scrolling.
We're going to find this, guys.
Where the fuck?
Is it?
Okay.
Give me a sec before I do all of this.
Give me a sec.
Let me find it.
I'm a little bit of a mess right now.
I forgot how to play.
I forgot the controls.
I forgot to save the audio and I forgot where I placed the
codes.
The secret codes.
The secret launch codes.
Where is it?
Where the fuck?
Oh, there is.
I got it.
Okay.
I got the codes.
All right.
Okay.
So we're going to do it like how we usually done it.
Let me set this.
up real quick i was gonna get it out of the way so i don't
forget again i always pick it like end of the stream but
always at the end of the stream i'm so tired i just forget
about it but this time for real now because i'm not i'm not
sponsored or contractually obligated so it's like not on the
top of my head to be like remember to do this dokey um so
because i'm not i'm not contractually obligated so like you
know i don't have any risk to not give the codes or like
being like oh you break the contract so it's not always
always not on the top of my head because i'm like oh it's
okay it's not like i'm gonna get sued or anything like so
that's why i always remember i always remember and the other
times i've done code giveaways because it's in my contract
it's because i'm contractually obligated to remember to do
this on this stream because of course i don't want to get
sued or any lawsuit but then this one is just me they just
gave me some code and i was like you know what i'm gonna
give it to some dragons because you know it is my first
first voice acting gig, but I was not contractually
obligated to do so.
So I sometimes, so I always forget about it because it's not
on my top of my head.
We're like, you're going to get sued because it's not there.
So I'm just like, oh, okay, I could just do it tomorrow.
It's not.
I'm not sponsored, by the way.
I'm not sponsored.
They just only hired me as a voice actress.
I got paid for voice acting, so I'm not sponsored.
I didn't, none other than that.
I'm not sponsored by it.
How we're going to do this, as always, it is exclamation
point enter.
That's how you, is that how you spell it?
Yeah, that's how, okay, it is exclamation point enter.
And when you enter the giveaway, I haven't started yet,
guys.
I haven't started the thing yet.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God, you guys already did it.
It already caught you guys.
So, as you always know, as all, like all the other previous
giveaway, that we've done before.
You have to follow.
If you win the giveaway, you have to follow.
Well, you don't have to follow.
I don't think you have to.
But, like, you have to have a Twitter account.
Sorry.
You have to have a Twitter account.
So you can DM the Doki merch Twitter account.
And they will DM you.
No, no.
You DM them.
And they will reply back.
with the code so that's really all you have to do so you
have to have a twitter account and you have to you have to
contact them we're not going to contact you you have to
contact because we realize it just makes it a lot harder it
makes it a lot more harder so um we're just gonna make it so
that uh you just have to dm the dokey merch twitter account
and then they will reply back uh with your code and you have
to show proof that you're that's your youtube account
basically If not, if not, if you do not have a Twitter
account, look, how about this?
If you do not have a Twitter account, you can also email the
dokey can read business email to claim your code.
You can also do that.
Oh my God, did I tell you guys during the last giveaway?
I don't remember if I told you guys the story, but during
the last giveaway, I actually miscounted the amount of
people that were supposed to win the last giveaway.
I'm trying to remember what game was it.
What was the game for the MSI one?
I actually gave two extra codes Because I forgot to count So
I actually accidentally gave it Two extra codes To people
And we didn't My manager was like, Turkey You gave more You
gave You picked too many dragons It's supposed to be it Like
I was like, I thought it was 10 He's like, no, we got eight
codes Like
But I was like, but you said it was like last time.
It's like, he's like, in the briefing, there's eight codes.
He's like, he's like, Doki, in the, I was like, you said it
was like last time.
Last time, I gave 10 codes for rest and evil.
And he was like, yes, but also in the briefing, there's
eight codes.
And look, he said it was like last time.
And I was like, oh, so there's 10 codes.
And he's like, Doki, in the briefing, there's eight codes.
Like, so a little bit of an oopsie there.
I round it up.
I did read the briefing.
There were so many codes.
I didn't, it didn't give me a number how many codes there
are.
I just saw a bunch of codes.
I assume that's 10.
You know, that looks like 10 codes.
I Please, you can't read I did read the briefing I just
didn't count the amount of codes I looked at the list of
codes I was like That looks like 10 That So luckily Ben
thankfully We We asked if they could give us two more extra
codes So thank you MSI For coming in clutch and give us two
additional Game codes Because like oops what actually we
only asked for one extra code because my manager was like i
guess i'll give them my code
and i was like luckily i also got a code from msi so i guess
i could give i'll give them my code so so yeah this time i
know we have three i counted this time we have three game
codes so I now I learned chat now I learned to count the
amount of codes I'm given look they said it was like last
time and like last time I was giving 10 game codes okay so I
assumed it looked like 10 it looked like also 10 my head
rounded up anyway I can count of three yay So anyway, so
exclamation point enter to let me I could write it on the
thing Oh, where is the text thing?
All right, I'll do where is the text luckily this time I'll
know how to count.
Are you sure?
Enter for gold, gold adventure gold code give up.
away uh dm at dokey merch or email business email if one
okay if you win please uh if no claim in 24 hours you lose
okay there you go it's it's a little big but don't worry i
can resize this should be informative.
It's a lot of information, but it should be informative
enough.
And then background.
There you go.
Alright.
Enter for gold, gold, adventure, gold giveaway.
DM at Doki merch or
holy shit, my GoXLR reset.
Oh, whoops.
My GoXLR like reset itself for a little bit.
I don't know if it made anything noise because I
accidentally I touched the power plug and it was like It did
like a little dance Oh my gosh Yeah am I still Yeah okay
Alright I accidentally like touched the power cable for it
And it did a It did a little A little dance Yeah It went
crazy I was like wow It went rainbow Alright I accidentally
touched the power cable I should not Because my GoXLR is not
NA It's European I think it's not a European or Asian I
don't know I think it's it's one earth it's I it's European
so um uh it's a I should buy a new one but also they've I've
heard go XLR is gone gone now like they've like they don't
update the software anymore and it's also they don't really
make it anymore either so I don't know if I can buy a new go
XLR anymore uh yeah so um it's because like I got this goxlr
is like four plus years old i believe it's old it's an old
it's old um and um and i had to get it uh i basically it was
basically i got it from europe i got it like overseas um so
yeah god like no it's god like it's stream elements actually
um but also they're coming back apparently stream elements
made a deal with somebody and people are like i do people
are like freaking up about like which deal did you make it
with stream elements so it's coming back anyway anyway are
you guys ready all right we have three codes all right three
two one choose winner terminator congratulations on you the
first dragon to win a game code yeah
That's Dragoon number one.
Who won their very own.
Remember to...
Oh, wait.
Give us a message if you're here to claim it.
Oh, my God.
He's like, what?
Me?
Yes, you?
You won the code.
That's right.
You got it.
Just make sure to DM DokeyMarch or email business email if
you win.
And make sure to prove that this is your account as well.
All right, we're doing another winner.
Thank you.
Second winner!
All right, type in chat if you're here to claim the prize.
What was the email?
Doki can read at gmail.com.
I figured it'd be easier for those who don't have Twitter,
you know.
Doki can read at gmail.com or at Doki merch on Twitter,
whichever one you want.
one is easy just make sure you attach uh you send images
that proving that that is your youtube account um that has
won the giveaway code yay all right anyway tarkus
congratulations make sure to dm dokey much or email the
business email um to claim your game code all right last
dragoon the last code guys last code last dragoon Here we
go.
The last dragon, the last lucky dragon that's going to get
this game.
Three, two, one.
Bada-dang.
Bromers Simpson at 700.
Congratulations.
Type in chat.
Doki, this is three.
Yeah, okay, this is number three, guys.
I know this is the last one.
I can count this time.
Type in chat if you're here What, me?
Yeah, it's you You got it, you won Congratulations You did
it Alright, you guys all have 24 hours to claim the game
code If you don't claim it It's guy It goes to someone else
If you don't claim it Okay, this is usually what happens
When people don't claim the game code, we just, we, like, we
give it to the, we give it to, like, staff, staff slash, uh,
uh, volunteers, basically.
So if you don't claim it, go straight to them, because,
like, then I don't have to host another giveaway randomly.
So make sure to claim it, guys.
Make sure to claim it.
Yeah.
Um, so remember to grab your, grab your game.
Game code, everyone.
Anyway, guys.
Yeah, they get the unclaimed codes.
The ones people who win, but don't claim it.
And the mod's like, I'm going to start banning now.
Don't let them get it.
It's like the Christmas bonuses.
Anyway, guys.
Other than that, what other news?
Yeah, it's on Steam.
These are all Steam.
game codes by the way he's all seen game codes anyway what
else what else other announcements we are we have just
announced 50 more vip tickets uh for the dokey dokey rewind
time this was something i requested uh because i saw how
fast it sold out so i wanted to give one more chance for
people to get the dokey dokey rewind time vip tickets it
comes with an exclusive merch uh exclusive merch or freebie
which is a postcard signed by me uh still not sure if
chibi's also gonna be signing it but i will definitely be
signing a exclusive postcard merch uh that will only go to
vip's and um and uh but but what else and you also get to be
there or get to get better seats uh and basically like
benefits of vip um tomorrow will be the last guest
announcement uh for the concert and that would be the last
one no it's hand signed it's not digitally signed it's me
actually signing all these cards so i requested that 50
marion last the final vip drops for it so this is the last
one we won't be releasing any more vip tickets yes all the
vip the the exclusive merch will be hand signed by me uh i
will be signing it because i will be there like of course
like Like, of course I'd be signing it.
I'd be there.
I'm going to be there.
So, yes, I will be hand signing all the postcards for the
VIPs.
And, yeah, I'm super excited.
Like I said, the last guest announcement will be tomorrow.
Thank you all for the huge support for this entire concert
so far.
I really, really appreciate it.
Streaming tickets, it's still being worked on, guys.
do not worry it's still being worked out on we're getting
updates about it they're having conversations with the the
stream the with the people who are handling the streaming
streams and stuff so they're still uh they're they're
they're still working on it so do not worry it's still being
worked on uh i don't know when it's gonna be done the
negotiations and everything but my the latest update was
that still being worked on and everything and that you know
they're having conversations they had to stop conversation
because it was golden week but after golden week was over
like you know they restarted like not restarted but they
continued the conversation that's all i know about the
streaming tickets but it's still you know still being worked
on at least yay
so i i'm trying really hard to grab get streaming tickets
for all the guys but yes um if you You can upgrade your
ticket to a VIP ticket.
So, oh yeah, let me get this text away.
So if you guys already bought a general admissions ticket
but wasn't able to get a VIP ticket, do not worry.
You can upgrade it to a VIP ticket.
I did see someone ask how it's done and then I messaged them
about it and they were like, oh, it should be able to, but
we're going to look into it.
But if you're unable to upgrade your GA ticket, I would
recommend emailing or...
sending a message to the fantastic reality people and then
they can help you sort it out for you.
I don't know how any of that's done.
I don't handle the ticket stuff.
I'm just here to perform.
I'm just here to show up, sing, dance and be like, yay.
I don't handle the logistics.
I'm sorry.
I really don't know how to upgrade stuff.
I just know you can upgrade it.
That's all I know.
That's like all I know is that You can upgrade your ticket
Because I saw So it's like, how do you do it?
I was like, I don't know So yeah, so let me just put this
here VIP tickets The VIP tickets Last call for them After
it's gone, it's gone Um What else, there is Is there one?
There was one more thing I want to talk about.
I'm trying to remember what it is.
Maybe I'll write it down.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Yes, there is one.
Very important thing I want to show you guys.
This is very important.
Look at this video.
I just think it's a pretty neat video, guys.
Don't worry.
Play it.
I'll play it on the stream.
Wait, is this?
No, is this.
Is this one?
I love this video.
Mina-san, Konnichiwa!
It's basically a T-Rex.
At a fucking museum, he's like, Ah!
Minasan, Konichiwa!
A donkey crate will have to 1 to 5.
It wasn't on Steam, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, it looks like it just, it tickles my funny bone.
It really does.
Made me really be.
I need to listen to it again.
He's like,
Minasan Konichiwa
It's good!
It's a good video
Minasan Konichiwa It sounds like It sounds like a school
teacher It's good It's like a fucking funny video i love it
it made me happy all right whatever thing i want oh yeah but
also did you guys see the one where uh do you guys see how
pokemon is doing a uh a pokemon fossil museum i think that's
cool i actually sort of want to go to chicago to see it i
think that's so cool like that has like actual fossils next
to like uh pokemon like next to like had made pokemon
fossils too as if they were like they were like around that
time that's so sick i actually sort of really want to go
just to see that uh even though like a lot of the fossils
are like more of the new gen pokemon i still think it's
pretty sick uh i like here for those who haven't seen it
yeah we gotta see yeah you get to see dead pokemans there
actual pokemon fossils yeah apparently they they limited the
merch so that you can only buy one of each item and also we
can only pick five different items or something.
I think that was like the rule for limited merch.
Scalpers are still going to figure out the scalp.
This is the one thing I feel really sad about is that
society is all about scalping now.
And like fandoms are all about scalping.
And it's not really about like collecting for the love of
the game.
It's more so it's just collecting just because it's gonna be
worth something in the future so and i it was it's just very
sad to see because i saw like a video of this um i saw a
video and i think it was like a little kid who was just like
being like this card cost a thousand three hundred dollars
and he was like seven or something and i was like i don't
feel like seven year olds should like worry about like you
know It's like, you know, when I was collecting Pokemon, I
was like, oh, it's my favorite Pokemon.
They're like, oh, it's so cute.
It's so cute.
But now they're like, oh my God, look, I just got a $1,300
card, $1,300 card and everything.
Oh my God.
I can't wait to send it to PSA and get it graded on the PSA
and everything.
And it's just like, I don't know.
I just said that everything is just about like the monetary.
value uh the monetary value of uh of the item not because of
like you know you you enjoyed you enjoyed the fandom or yeah
it's not whimsy and yeah there's there's no whimsy anymore
to it it's all about like money um because i used to collect
pokemon cards as a kid and like i well i i was more so of a
yugioh card collector back then because i just liked the
cards in general i didn't I didn't play the game.
I just liked the cards and I all had them put in a little
those Ikea color box like I didn't even put it in like
binders or anything.
I put it in these like Ikea color boxes like a huge stack of
them as if they're all like um as if they're like uh what
are they called?
I know there's like a word for it in Pokemon where they're
not like the hollows or anything they're just like uh what
is it called like the the the junk cards i know there's a
term for them but i don't remember what they're called bulk
yeah yeah yeah i treated every card like it's a bulk card i
didn't care i when i was i just chucked i don't care if it's
rare or not i chucked all my cards in these little boxes um
my pokemon cards they did get a binder they did get a buying
it, but my Yu-Gi-Oh cards, they were just giant, all the
cards were just in these little IKEA boxes.
I did not care.
I just liked how pretty they looked.
I was like opening and looking through the cards.
They're all equal, exactly.
They're all equal in my eye.
No one has, no one has more value than the other.
I was a fucking kid.
I don't fucking know.
I just saw all the cards look cool but I feel like nowadays
it's all about like how much certain items cost now not
because like oh I love this I like they're like oh um I love
this particular uh character or like I love this fandom so I
like collecting all of them it's more so like this this is
worth $2,000 and I'm gonna package it so it'll be worth even
more in the future it's like holy grail yeah even the kids
care about the value now um uh terminator thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you the weird thing about it is
that it looks exactly like the t-rex animatronic from the
natural history museum in london thank you the super chat
thank you thank you yeah all cards are equal but some cards
are more equal than others yeah i was like i understand if
like you know it's a super 50 oh my god i think he wants for
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna give- he's like at my door.
I'm gonna go feed him.
That will hold him off for a little bit.
I don't feed him the entire can.
Um, because he did eat like four hours ago.
Um, but yeah, I don't care.
Like, I don't mind if it's like adults, but if it's a little
kid rattling about prices and stuff, it just feels like the
whimsy is gone, you know?
I just- just feels like the whimsy is gone now.
yeah
well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you did
you see the person on the 100 plus kabutops yeah uh i
remember he raised the value of it but then it got like i
like how larpers is the new gen z term for posers now yeah
well we're calling them larpers it's language is is
interesting we now call posers larpers language is is very
interesting it's always changing um but yeah it's like uh
but then it got a lot of larpers into pokemon collecting
cards and trying to inflate they try to inflate prices now
of certain bad cards uh just to like pretend there's like
monetary value actual demand for it um which is weird
um yeah it's and then it's like uh and then uh now that uh
for those who don't know uh let's see oh yeah before i get
in i'm gonna be okay i'll talk about this after my this
tangent but there's also like uh what what was it oh yeah
because now uh for those who don't know uh China just
recently.
Well, not recent, recent.
I would say, like, either this year or the start of last,
the start, I think it was, like, I remember it was, like,
start of this year or the end of last year where China
finally has official Pokemon cards.
And because they finally have official Pokemon cards, they
have a lot of catching up to do to catch up with the current
cards.
Because if you guys didn't know, trading cards are super
popular in China.
That's how My Little Pony got really, really popular.
in China because of the My Little Pony trading card game and
through the My Little Pony trading card game, My Little Pony
blew the fuck up last year because everyone got introduced
to it via the trading card game.
That's why you see all these new merch and everything coming
from China.
And because of that, yeah, they basically, it's like a new
renaissance.
Milo Pony, the last Gen 4 Milo Pony just because of the Milo
Pony TCG that released in China and it like blew up and like
Normies loved it, like Normies and China loved it and then
like you know like everybody loved Milo Pony and you'll see
Milo Pony merch everywhere right now in China and you see a
lot of them coming out from there at the moment.
And because of that, trading card games are introduced uh
pokemon uh pokemon in the china they recently got the
license for it and because of that like now chinese pokemon
cards are blowing up at the moment and um and um and there's
like i heard like everyone's trying to get even for here
everyone's trying to scalp the chinese tcg set right now um
because there's apparently they're they're following you
know they're using reusing because they're playing catch up
you know they're playing catch up because they missed out on
a lot of the sets since they just started getting into it
and but because of because um for the newest set uh although
they are still taking you know because like in in in n a we
just take the sets from japan you know we just get them from
japan and we just you know rename like you know localize it
and everything so we don't really get exclusive cards for
those who don't know the NA set is practically the same to
the Japanese set it's just localized into English but in
China they have exclusive cards so they have some of the
sets that are from previous Japanese sets but they also have
each set each box has one exclusive card that you can only
get And because of that, people in NA are hard scalping
those sets right now.
Yeah, because they have exclusive cards that you cannot get
in the Japanese sets or in the English set at all.
So that's like the current thing going on at the moment.
I don't remember what the Chinese set is called.
I just know that they have three cards.
It's like the Pikachu card.
the Q-Bone card and the Ponyta card.
So these three cards are like going like crazy right now
because of the, you know, it's only included in the Chinese
set.
I've been like watching a lot of like videos about it
because it's popping up like, because it was really
interesting to me.
It was really interesting to me.
And it's like, it's really weird because like the card, you
know how like it's card shows, you know, it's like card
shows and everything and um um you know you can get these at
card shows i never went to the card show before but i
thought it was really weird i think the one thing i think is
really weird is that they come some of the youtubers there
because they film everything they stream it and everything
too uh of them making their sales and stuff selling their
cards and everything But they're also scalpers, right?
They are also scalpers, because they're getting these sets,
these cards, and they're scalping it at a higher price.
But then they complain about other scalpers.
So it's like, you are part of the problem, though.
Like, these card shows, it's mostly just scalpers, right?
So you are part of the problem.
You can say, like, yeah, but they're more passionate
about...
They actually love the, they love Pokemon.
They love, they love collecting and everything.
Like they're doing, they're scouting for the passion.
They're not scoping for the money, but it's still, but
they're like, yeah, they're ethical scalpers, but they're
also still scalpers.
Like, I don't understand.
Like, just, I, it's like, just, you know, own it, you know?
Don't be like, I'm the better scalper.
I'm because I don't like I don't take advantage of the
children because their whole premise the whole mindset is
that they don't take advantage of the children because if a
kid wants a card they they try to like sell it for cheaper
to them or give it to them for free or something so you know
they're like oh I'm an ethical scalper because um you know
uh I try to get the scouts to kids or if the kid won a card
I try to give it to them or something or like you know
there's I see someone still scalping like they could get
this card cheaper if they if like there wasn't a scalping
problem you're still you're still scalping like you are
buying these cards you are you have these cards cheaper and
you are selling them at a more expensive price like i'm
pretty sure the booster set you got from china the way you
got it has to be a lot cheaper than what you're selling out
to people They're like, oh, yeah, these Chinese booster sets
are like a hundred plus dollars or something.
Like, um, but like, obviously, if you've ever been to China,
you know how cheap these things are.
There's no way.
Cause like, there's no way.
Like, let me see.
Okay.
Chinese Pokemon card box price.
I'm trying to remember how much it was cost.
Cause it's like, it's like a hundred plus dollars.
Yeah.
Um, trying to remember that what the fuck the boxes were and
what they were called box by i remember it was like a
hundred plus dollars like 150 dollars or something but do
you know how 150 usd to remnb is like a thousand remnb i am
pretty sure it did not cost a thousand remnb in for these
box sets I'm pretty sure you can get it a lot cheaper if you
buy it in China like 150 US for a box set yeah that's like
maybe the normal price it is in America but I've been to
China and I know they're not they're they're not that
expensive
Like that cannot be market price.
I am so positive.
Like that, there's no...
If it is that, I would be blown away.
I would be blown away if that is market price.
I know that's not market price.
Like...
I know it's not market price.
$150 US?
That's a thousand RMB.
For him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a good thing They can scalp super chats.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, and there's a lot.
I will agree.
There are a lot of fakes And stuff too.
So I'm Just, I just thought it's weird.
Just I don't, I like, just own up to the fact That you were
also a scalper.
Like Just Don't be like, I'm an ethical scalper But you are
still a scalper.
You're There's like, I just I find it fucking weird like
There's still You're still part of the problem Like You're
Yeah I'm not like other girls Like I'm different Like
Gordon Thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you It's
like every hobby has to have a monetary purpose Or else it's
a waste of time It sucks What happened to doing something
for the love of the game Man you thank you i know it's true
that's why i have a problem right now regarding like um
scalping cart culture and the like larpers and stuff for
them think uh thinking of the super chat i think i know i
just read it um that's i'm glad i'm not into card collecting
um because like uh i'm i i've never been like super in the
card collecting um so i'm glad like you know um i can thing
to worry about for my money for my bank account oh really
first day the museum opened a binder sold out of the i'm not
surprised i i am not surprised that uh that it sold out
really fast like i said like literally people were scalping
the one piece pop eyes Like, cardboard boxes.
I talked about it before.
But, people were literally...
Like, that was never a thing before.
I swear if people...
Remember the Burger King?
The Burger King Pokemon Gold Cards?
If those were released today, we would not have been...
No one would have been...
None of the kids would have been able to get it.
I would tell you that.
Like, if those...
The Burger King Gold Cards.
If those were released today, this year it would be sold out
on the first day and we bought and you have to get it via
like ebay or something for like five times the price jokes
on you my one-on-one turkey made checky has at least tripled
in value papa thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you people are willing to scalp fucking one piece of
cardboard boxes i like i'm glad um i i got a goal plated
pokemon card uh back then i don't i don't know if i still
have it um but i feel like a lot of like stuff would not
have been able to a lot of things wouldn't be able to be a
purchase like you wouldn't be able to a lot of things that
were released back in the day i feel like it would just been
scalped instantly um like the movie card too if you want to
guys remember during like when they released the exclusive
cards that you get from going to like Pokemon movies and
stuff like the 2,000, what was it, the ancient Mew and all
of that shit I feel like it would have been gone on the
first day.
Like you would not be able to get, like as a kid you would
not be able to get it from watching the movie.
Devil, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, I saw that.
And sometimes they throw the food away just for the cards.
I saw a tweet about in Japan people were so mad about it and
that's why they had to uh because I think it was McDonald's
they had an exclusive collab uh with Pokemon for a card I
think it was either a Pokemon card or Sanri or a Sanrio
thing it was like Pokemon card or Sanrio or Chikawa I don't
remember but there was a special collab in Japan for an
exclusive that you can only get in Japan McDonald's ordering
like 10 bags of it and they would just grab the toy and just
leave it out like just leave it on the floor and just waste
the fluid or like throw it in the trash i remember it was
last year too it was so bad and then people were and people
in japan were so mad because um you can literally see the
mcdonald's bags just like littered around like near all the
mcdonald's stores and stuff And there was, because there was
no limit.
People were literally just buying the meal just for the toy.
It was so fucked up.
Yeah, it was really, really bad.
Just to scalp it, too.
They were, like, just scalping it overseas and everything.
It was just terrible.
I was just, I was like, oh my God.
Yeah, because that's just a waste of food.
Yeah.
That, uh, that's just such a waste of food and everything.
Oh, yeah, I saw that, too.
because how bad scalping has gotten in Japan.
Japanese stores selling TCG cards or TCG packs, they cut the
packs.
They cut the corner of the pack to lower the value of it,
which is smart.
Just to try and deter scalping as much as they can.
They started cutting the corners of the TCG packs just so
the value will be lost much as they can uh and everything
like just to lose the value yeah yeah and i i like i i get
it because the problem has only i feel like the problem has
only just gotten worse and worse lately it really has um i
feel like i don't think it's gonna stop anytime soon um and
uh and you know I don't know.
It's just, I feel like, yeah, the problem is just getting
worse in general.
Dead guy.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Scalpers, aka.
Pay to win.
Hoarders really just ruin every hobby.
Dead guy.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Oh my God.
Did you guys, oh, and people, I saw another YouTube short.
Sorry for yapping in a lot.
But I've been like really interested in this.
topic because it's very interesting like it's very
interesting how how bad the problem has gotten lately and to
see the things people have been doing to try to prevent it
but i saw like for pokemon cards apparently for some sets
you could use a metal detector or something like a metal
detector to detect hollow cards i was like what so i saw
youtube short it just it came out in my And basically
they're like, can this set be, um, be, can this set be used
to do, uh, metal detect if the card is a good pack or not?
Uh, so apparently some Pokemon sets, um, if you know it has
a, basically has a, what's it called, a hollow or better,
you can use a metal detector and like find which pack is a
bad pack and which, I know the weighing, the weighing thing,
everybody knows about the weighing thing because hollow
cards are heavier.
But they put weights in it now to like deter it a little
bit.
Unless it's a God pack.
So, but now there's some sets where that's why people like
don't buy packs anymore.
Like, because of the thing, you can't even buy random packs
anymore.
You have to buy the box, the sealed box.
So it encourages people to buy the fully sealed box because
you can't trust random card packs anymore to buy because
some people will just sell the shitty packs now.
They would just sell packs that they know is, doesn't have,
um, what's it called?
Doesn't have, like, a good card in it or a hollow in it
because they don't even have to open it to realize or reseal
the pack to realize, um, if it's a bad, if it's a bad pack
or not.
They can weigh it.
They can use a metal detector now.
They can, like, there's so many stuff they can do.
So people just have to buy the boxes.
to buy the boxes to deter so they can do their hobby and you
know like get cars that they want it's fucking crazy it's
actually insane that i think the the way part like yeah
everyone knows about the way part i the fact that you can
use a metal detector is like a whole new level yeah but what
if i don't want to buy a box i as a kid i'll go to like EB
which is the Canadian version of EA I don't fucking know why
ours was EB I'll go to a you know a local EB store and just
buy a Pokemon pack like or like you know we're at a grocery
store they're selling Pokemon packs I buy a poke I'll be
like mom I want a Pokemon pack I buy a pack and then and
then and then that's it but now you don't apparently you
don't even oh sorry I I meant EB is like GameStop.
Sorry, ours is EB Games.
You guys have GameStop.
I thought it's not EA.
Sorry, our GameStop is EB.
Anyway, but now you can't do that because you're the kid.
Well, most likely, if they do it now, they buy like a, just
a random card pack.
You just get, they just get shit.
They get nothing.
They just get nothing, yeah Yeah, they have to No parent
wants to buy a fucking box Like that's so much 150 US
dollars For Because like a regular card pack Is like what
Five, ten dollars back in the day Like that's something a
parent can just You know, be like Fine, I'll treat you to a
card pack You know It's You know, they'll be like, you're
like, mommy, daddy, can I have a, can I buy a Pokemon card
pack, please?
Like, you know, while they're like, just, yeah, and then,
or, and now it's like, like, you don't want to buy a random
card pack, because then the kid won't get shit.
Like, yeah, you want your kid to have a good experience.
You have to buy a $150 card box.
Who wants to buy a $150 card box?
fucking buy that it's like um but that's just that just
grinds my gears i feel bad for the kids that's really i just
i feel like you know it's just a loss to whimsy you know a
lot just the loss of whimsy um patu esther they even super
chat that you think you saw someone posting about how the
staff has store sliced the cling wrap to protect from
scalpers and scalpers trying to get the left without buying
that's that's that's fucking gross so thank you the super
chat thank you thank you um broken by think of a super chat
thank you thank you the simplest solution to scalpers is to
never buy a second-hand shit yeah people keep saying that
but someone will buy like you can't stop you can't stop
people from doing like someone will buy it eventually like
there are some scalpers who can't scalp like you know
there's some items that people have stopped buying but i
Pokemon cards, you can't really stop it.
Yeah, someone will eventually cave in because it's Pokemon.
It's Pokemon cards.
And I feel like, um, um, it's, and because of like, it's
such a fat, it turned into a craze, like, opening Pokemon
packs now.
So, like, it's like, I don't know.
It's just such a, it's like the current trend.
It's like those stupid shitty, uh, dumpling.
dumpling squishies.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm yapping so much.
But like, did you guys see the stupid fucking dumpling?
The dumpling gotcha boxes or whatever.
The dumpling squishies.
So basically, okay.
I'm like, you guys cannot shit talk la boo-boos when.
Anyone that's in.
Okay.
I'm going to say like, like people cannot shit talk la
boo-boos.
when there's like when people are now freaking out I feel
like that's worse that's so much at least the labubus are
like high quality like I will say the labubus at least worse
at least so much for high quality than this so the newest
craze right now in NA for the normies by the way there's
like a whole normie craze um yes they are they're actually
very quality.
I, I, I, like, I, when I was in the, in China for the Marvel
Revival's land, um, they gave me a Labu as a gift, like the
staff gave me Labuu, and they're actually surprisingly,
because, like, they're, they're very high quality.
That's why they're so expensive.
Like, they're, that's why they're so expensive.
They're, they're very high quality for what they are.
Um, but the dumpling squishies though the dumpling squishies
it's literally okay it's literally it's just slime and
glitter it's just it's it's so much worse the yeah the
dumplings are gotcha too I've seen the videos let me I don't
know why I don't know why I bookmarked it but basically the
um basically what they are is they're just squishies that's
all they're just squishies and you buy these little dumpling
boxes and then you open them to see if if it's a glitter
squishy if it's a glitter dumpling and it looks so cheap it
looks so much i feel like you can i i can tell you that
these are so much cheaper than they look they look so much
cheaper than a labubu and i have a feeling they are so
expensive they aren't expensive as a labubu but they
definitely upsell it by at least 10 times and how much they
actually cost and at least like the color okay at least like
when you're gotching a labubu at least the colors they look
nice but like the rare the rare version of a dumpling is
like it's just glitter it's just they add glitter to it
that's not what makes it rare they add this glitter on the
squishy and that once makes it special and i'm just like bro
this has consumerism gone too far that's like the point
where i was like have we gone too far have we have we gone
too far with consumerism we really it's i don't know we made
it as a society let me say i need to see if i can find it i
need to find this video all right the i need i when i watch
it i'm just like this has to be sad but it's not it's not
sad to Tire.
Oh, there it is.
I found him.
This is this is what this is what I'm talking about.
This is what the thing is it's like
I think this is worse.
This is worse than LaBoufou.
Like we didn't know how bad it could get.
Like we didn't know how bad it could get when when we were
ragging And the booboos, like, I think this is worse.
I, I, I.
For those who want to see the video, here you go.
Here's the video.
What?
Like, it's just, it's, what am I looking at?
Like, it's just, it's a squishy.
And the rare one is just glitter.
It's not even that cute.
It's like, it's this rock bottom.
I know I thought it was AI.
I thought it was satire.
But it's not.
It's not satire.
The super rare dumpling cost is $250.
What do you mean?
This is $250.
He has sunglasses on.
What do you mean?
This is $250.
And do you know how much it costs?
It's 25.
The retail.
Guys, do you know what the retail price is for these?
It's $5 to $10.
It's five, ten, ten dollars.
They're like, yeah, reinventing CS loot boxes from first
principle.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Look at this!
Did you remember we saw the glitter one?
Look how much it sold for!
The vital mystery dumpling
What the fuck No apparently it was sold for a thousand This
is sold for a thousand It's a It's a It's a It was actually
sold for a thousand Hey guys, thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you, please keep on Yeah, so I'm like super
passionate about this About this topic Like I've just been
like Oh my god I can find I can find GPU I can find the
Uplits It's like It's like it's based off of anything just
the people just do it for like the thrill of a mystery box
anyway i should release a mystery box soon never stick it
with a super chat thank you thank you that is a blob of
silicone you can make from a hobby lobby kid at home i
refuse to believe those are not all paid actors thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you i shall be part of
the problem
oh yeah okay all right sorry final thing I want to talk
about we're going to move on we're going to move on from
this topic oh my god I've been yapping for I think this has
been the longest yaff session so far um what happened to the
sticker oh yeah the sticker gotcha merch I did everything's
just been like I was working on that and then and then
everything got postponed don't worry don't worry when I have
the time it will be we will be going back to it but thank
you super chat doc thank you thank you um what was i say yes
i'll be in the apex tournament next week i think it's next
week um if anyone saw it apparently uh what's this name uh
i'm trying to remember the streamer so there's apparently a
big apex tournament that's gonna be hosted that's gonna be
on on the 29th From this Rainbow Six Siege player.
Bolo?
Bolo.
I think.
And one of my friends, Albert Lely, got invited as a
captain.
And they needed a gold player.
And a Apex content creator.
And then I was like, I can be the gold player.
Okay, apparently it's bad to the point where people are...
At first?
thought uh i could be the gold player because at first they
were like yeah she can be the gold player because i was like
i haven't really played apex and i haven't touched rank um
in two years basically um i haven't uh touched rank in two
years so i've been gold technically for two plus years now
because i haven't touched rank and i haven't grinding a ring
i've just been you know i haven't played apex that much or
anything so um so i've first the organizers were like yeah
she can count as a gold player i'm so washed guys please i
promise it's true though it's true but it's true i don't
know what the current meta is i don't know what the current
meta is i just know everybody's fucking sliding around with
the new character which is fun i played a little bit it was
really fun i wasn't playing the slidey girl because it was
too fast um you know me when characters are too fast i like
lost track of stuff um so um anyway so um and then so
basically what happened was that the whole premise was that
it needs to be one pro player one apex content creator and
one gold max player like gold or worse player the thing is
apparently they're struggling so hard to find streamers that
are Because a lot of people have already, you know, got
higher than gold.
Apex has been around for a long time.
And a lot of FPS streamers have been, you know, have peaked
higher than gold.
So, you know, you're not really going to get an FPS
streamer.
No, the thing is, they made a new rule.
So they're like, okay, we're going to make it, to make it
fair for everybody, for their gold player.
the player cannot have peaked above cannot have reached
masters and above that was the new rule that they came up
with today so um so they're like all right because it's
gonna be very hard to find a gold player now they can't have
reached masters or above like at all in any season i was
just like i have but that was like season that's like three
years but so um so i couldn't be a gold player anymore i
couldn't be a gold player anymore but dokey you said you're
gonna be in a tournament next week so i was just like oh ggs
and then he was like you know i could put you as our print
content creator and i was like bro we're not gonna win i was
like i was like i do not want to over your chance Like, if
you want to win and do well, I should not be placed as the
Pred content creator, Mac.
I really shouldn't.
Because you know who are the other Pred content creators?
Do you know who are the other content creators on other
teams in this Apex tournament?
It's like Fade Lyric.
Oh, yeah, Timmy's considered a pro, apparently.
But Fade Lyric.
All these other players that have hit Pred, but are not.
not pro like consistent pred players who are currently poor
playing the game non-stop every day and has never left like
so uh uh appraise uh you know all these players that aren't
pro but they are consistently pred they are the they're on
the other teams i was like bro we're bro and you're hard
nerfing your team if you put me on that slot and he was like
nah it's cool i just i don't care about winning as long as
we place well and i was like that's the point bro like you
want to play swell i'm literally the coffin big coughing
baby i was just like no man you want to place well you're
putting me on the pred content creator spot and he's like
don't worry he's like don't worry dokey i got as a
controller warzone player to be our gold player so it's at
least two controller players and we should be fine and i was
like i warned you i was like i as long as you're cool with
that and you are going in aware of where you're putting me
it froze so much trust as long as you are because i just
wanted to play i i guys i warned i warned him i just wanted
to play i i did it
so anyway i'm gonna be in this apex tournament next week i'm
really thankful for mac for letting me join his team you
know i i did warn him but look he was okay with he was cool
with it our team is the i i would try my best I will try my
best, but if our team ended up being for the vibes team, I,
I, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
He's a real one.
Yeah, Mac is a real one.
So, yeah, he's, he's a homie.
He's a, he's a bro.
So, so anyway, I'm going to be in an Apex tournament next
week.
be streaming it we'll see how it goes we're gonna see how it
let's aim for not last guys my my goal for that tournament
is not last he said he wants to place well that's my
definition of placing well as i have one week to learn the
new meta new guns and what to do uh not last yet uh I'm like
a little baby beast like like we got to take you out of our
time one last job doki
so um so yeah that's thankful for Mac for letting me in on
uh for letting me in on the team um but fortunately couldn't
be considered a gold player I guess like the biggest issue
for me sometimes is be the worst like i don't fit the
definition of like a bad player but also i don't fit the
definition of a really really good player because i'm
variety you know i'm i'm variety so it's more so it's like
it's like sometimes they're looking for like casual players
and i don't fit the casual but sometimes they're making
they're looking for players who are the hardcore players but
i don't fit that i'm
i'm just in the middle category like i'm stuck in limbo but
i really appreciate mac for the invite like i said uh at
first i thought i was out out but then like you know he was
like no bro just be my bread content creator and i was just
like are you sure right yeah i was just like are you sure
and he's like yeah bro we were let's let's rip it let's roll
it um uh but yeah anyway so yeah i'll be uh i'll be doing
apex tournament next week on on friday yep it's on the 29th
all right that should be everything all right now we
actually play the video game after after all of that we're
finally here we're gonna play the video game i don't know if
Okay, sound guy is here, but like I said, sound guy, I
forgot to save the sound settings, so I need help.
I forgot to do it.
It's a little oopsie my bad.
So there was a lot of updates today.
Also, I love my bed.
The bed is so nice.
It is so fucking, it was so comfy.
Oh my gosh, I've got a bed upgrade earlier.
Oh my god, that mattress.
Mwah.
Oh, chef kiss.
it's so good i i can sleep on that bed forever it's so
comfortable yes
it's actually oh my god it's so good i love that bed i love
that bed so much
all right uh
Let's see.
Mina-san, Konichiwa.
I'm sorry.
I love that video.
It literally lives in my head, Red Free.
Mina-san, Konichiwa.
Ah!
Too bad you can't No, I can't become a taco Thank you for
this For Chad Zonderman Thank you, thank you Alright, I
don't remember the controls I don't remember the audio It's
gonna go great Alright, continue I still have the whimsy in
my heart
Oh my god, my beautiful Goodbye You're alive!
Yes!
That service.
505.
Selling ad space.
Every stream, I will sell ad space.
Does anyone, would anyone like to advertise anything?
It's one ad space per...
First come, first come.
save.
I'll stare you up.
Alright, I do need to do the tutorial again.
Um, where is this?
Training?
No, it wasn't training.
Where's the AC test, yes.
What?
For every stream, I'll accept I'll sell one advertising
space on Woonbot.
Alright.
Let's see.
One, two.
And then, okay, Q.
and E.
Okay, it's Q and E.
Yeah, but I'm trying to remember.
Okay, there you go.
And then there's that.
And then, okay, that's all the controls, I'm pretty sure.
That should be all the controls.
Yeah, alright.
Right, born a ship forced to wipe above the butt.
Alright, Gorda, thank you.
The super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Alright, it's gone now.
Let's see.
Ready the goomba.
quick bring doki a three kingdoms back thank you for the
super chat simple minded thank you thank you all right from
gordon let me grab all right where is it we'll grab it okay
okay oh whoa don't worry
all right it should be what color should it be i guess it
should be like um red is a A little too much, right?
So, make it light.
Actually, it's yellow.
It's yellow, and so I guess it should be red.
It's a little bad that it's red, but I don't think it can be
brown.
Because it's gonna, it won't be visible.
I bet that's, I mean, that's what you guys want.
Oh, hot pink.
Wait, I like that.
There we go.
We'll do pink.
Alright.
I wish I could type this out.
would be a lot easier I like the pink idea I like the hot
pink idea yeah
I'm born oh
I and
and oh my god wait this is gonna be hard I just realized how
How many letters there are?
Alright, we're gonna...
Oh, wait.
Born to shit.
Is there an S?
There's no other S.
Fuck!
Okay!
Discard this.
I forgot how to spell born for some reason.
I thought it was two ends.
I realized how long this is gonna be.
Wait, I can...
Oh, wait, I can copy this.
Wait, copy.
Born to...
Okay, S.
We can reuse letters, guys.
Oh my god.
We can reuse letters.
Born to shit.
Do I have an S?
Do I have an H?
Okay, do I don't have an H, so we get...
to shh it's a process guys oh shit do we need do we have a j
do we have a j god damn it we don't have a j it's h i'll do
exactly how you sponsored me to do it
yeah and then q oh Q.
Shit.
Oh, I forgot to do a comma.
Just like how you sponsored.
That's exactly how it was written.
Guys.
That's what the sponsor wanted.
There you go.
And then...
Get that.
Thank God.
I can copy and paste.
Wait, not that.
Alright, and then we need C, E, D.
We're almost there.
I just need a C.
And a N, and a D.
Okay.
Hold, hold, everybody.
We're almost there.
I have a D?
No.
Okay.
And then...
T,
and then another O.
Being efficient, guys.
We're so efficient right now.
Force, and then W.
Force, two, okay, you don't have an I, I just realized.
I never got an I.
And also a P.
And then the last part, this is very important.
so so they don't get me what are the what's the company
called what's the rule called where I have to disclose that
I'm sponsored I got him stay safe guys I got follow the law
you always have to disclose if you got sponsored I don't
want them to get me
hashtag ad hashtag sponsored
Uh, where the fuck is the P?
That's the...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait.
Ad might be faster.
You're right.
Okay, let's get rid of that.
I might as well just grab Ad.
No!
That was so good.
No.
I didn't sing.
Where's my auto sing?
Quick.
Control C and Control C.
We're almost there.
I didn't sing.
save.
Oh my god.
I'm not again.
Alright, we got the F.
I'm just gonna put that there somewhere.
Oh my God.
We were so close.
Oh, it was so beautiful.
It was so beautiful.
It was right there.
We were literally at the finish.
Oh my god.
Quick, dokey, control R.
Control R.
Control Z.
Reload.
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
I was so close.
It won't be as good.
That one was filled with so much love.
I had so much passion for that one.
It'll never be as good as the original.
It'll never be the same.
At least I'm faster with it now.
I feel like I'm, like, getting the hang of doing this.
The passion's not there anymore.
You're never gonna play the game now.
I ruined my...
No, this is good!
What do you mean, Terminator?
You got a free game code.
Does that not mean anything to you?
okay boring to shit okay
what do you mean for nothing you literally got a free game
what do you mean
it's not this this is not the same it's not as good as the
original I don't even remember what the original looked
like, but I knew it was pretty good.
I'm gonna wear a little cursive in here.
Let me make it a little fancy.
It doesn't have the sauce, you're right.
It'll never be as good as the original.
You're just a mere copy.
It's also more cramped, too.
I just noticed.
It's a lot more congested.
Where's the T?
Oh.
Okay.
W.
No, that's an R.
It's a cursive R, guys.
It's supposed to be classy.
That's the R cursive.
Okay.
It's classy.
You just don't understand my artistic vision.
That's literally the cursive.
Kiss these days.
Don't learn cursive anymore.
There we go.
And then...
Hashtag...
I should have been paid more.
I should have sold my ad space higher.
I should have charged more for ads.
Starting next stream.
The ad space will be more expensive.
What the fuck?
That's right.
I'm going to treat it like a New York Times Square ad.
Alright, it's done.
Hashtag.
Oh, I should change the color on this, actually.
Isn't that an ad?
Can I change the color?
Oh, I changed the color.
Oh, edit color.
There you go.
I'm making green.
Green for ads.
Green for money.
I'm trying to make sure I don't fuck it up again.
But I can do a gradient.
god wait what this changes everything oh it's so much cooler
now understandable i am amused apoc thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you
all right
confirmed how do i save i'm too scared i'm too scared how do
i save I like this photoshop key as I'm too scared I'm too
scared I'm not a lot save where is the save button where
where is it
oh my god
oh okay okay okay we got it we got it okay it was like legs
right
where do i move
okay where do i move my oh there it is
it's gonna be an issue
All right, it might not...
It can't go on the legs.
Okay.
All right, we can't put it on the legs.
We might have to put it on the core, maybe.
I might have put too much...
Too many decals.
There might be very limited ad space right now.
Oh, there you go.
It's like a little tramp stamp.
Okay, we can do that.
All right, let's...
Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah, there we go.
You sort of see it.
And there it is.
Born to shit.
Force.
If you align it correctly, you see force to wipe.
It's a little tramp stamp right here.
Here's my boobs.
It's beautiful.
There we go.
We got our...
There you go.
We sold another good day.
We sold another ad space.
Another ad space sold.
On the goon bot.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'm ready to start my mission now.
Alright.
All right, sound guy.
Are you ready?
Let me know our sound guy.
To all independent mercenaries, this request comes from
Schneider of the Archivist.
Schneider?
Then Schneider?
One of our adversaries allied with Baylam has introduced a
new tester, AC.
It's a sample model from an external architect featuring
extensive assembly optimization In the hands of an
experienced pilot, it will pose a threat far too great to
ignore.
This brings me to the request.
Yeah?
Intercept delivery of the Tester AC and destroyed.
Okay.
That's easy.
He's a noob.
I'm going to show him.
It's like when you're good at a game and you ask your friend
to play with him, to play with him, and then he's like, oh
you're gonna go easy on me right and you're like and you
don't go easy on him you teach him a lesson i'll never
forget oh i never played this game before you're gonna
you're gonna go easy on me right and like
friend you mean every multiplayer game yeah exactly you're
gonna learn today
knock knock i heard it's your first day
it's time it's hazing season boom boom boom
that's right i won't do Do not worry.
I got double missiles for a reason.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he has a knife.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, you gonna fail, bro.
Little, bro.
Bro, if I could, I would.
All I could do is shoot missiles.
Missile one.
Missile two.
Missile 3.
Stop moving!
Try to teach you a lesson!
Missile 2.
Missile 1.
Goodbye.
Little bro thinks he's the main character.
That's right.
Should have stayed in school, little bro.
Should have stayed in school.
Phew.
job done he wasn't ready for quick he wasn't ready for rank
go back to bot versus ai little bro little bro learning in
the hard way that was the anime for attacks you just killed
before he had the chance to shine should have stayed in
quick player versus ai little bro you ain't ready for
Yeah, don't bring a sword to a missile fight.
Yeah, welcome to the real world.
Little pro will never be a pro.
Little pro should have stayed in campaign.
Yeah, sure, stayed in single play, a little bro.
Go back to Wimu Hut Junior and Arc Raiders with the friendly
lobbies.
Don't shoot my ass.
I'm gonna love this group.
Oh, new message.
About the tester AC you downed.
That was being shipped to the Red Guns.
Balaam's in-house AC squad.
and its members are no amateurs.
Oh my god.
I killed somebody's little bro.
Wait, you mean he actually has a big bro?
No, no, that can't be.
Little bro has a big bro?
There's no way.
There's no way little bro has a big bro.
Oh no.
Not the big bro.
He's gonna bring big bro.
Should I get legs upgrades?
Should I get better legs?
Oh, that's like chidier legs.
Wait, why does this...
Oh, it's lighter.
Is it?
No, it's heavier.
How is this better?
Oh, it's faster.
Me rent.
Yeah, I was going to say I should get tank legs.
Should I save up?
I feel like I should save up.
Gurgo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't even know what to buy, honestly.
I get better arms.
You have a lot of money.
I'm gonna save up.
Alright, guys.
You guys help me create the perfect goon bot.
Wait, what is this?
Is that a better booster?
Oh, it is.
Wait, Ram card.
Do I not have this?
So after...
And this principle is designed to reduce missile lock tap.
Ooh!
What do I have for this?
Internal and especially modeled and plans lightweight.
Match with excellent bigger arm for the most equipment is
better alright I'll wait then I won't get anything yet am I
done oh I won't get anything yet should I get the faster
energy recharge or just save chat I could get the faster
energy recharge I get this or should I just save save my
money just save?
let's save all right was bring master up to eight yeah but i
don't i don't remember what my overall was i didn't save my
overall volume that was the issue yeah so if the is is the
sound okay or should i up it more is the audio okay yet so
far all right i'm gonna get water too while while you guys
figure it out i'm gonna get water i need refill water
i'm back i got my water get hydrated all right uh lacoon
solid neper cyber thank you the super chat thank you thank
you all right let's start another mission attack the damn
complex run to damn and destroy all generators facility
accompany oh i got a little buddy with me oh i got my little
oh my own little bro all right little bro good job for you
Okay.
What, am I a little bro?
No way.
But I have two missiles.
There's no way.
See, they're good for nothing.
Iguasso.
See?
They're just my backups.
my little bros gun 13 13 let's go allows you to resell parts
that you bought allowing the test out bills will have oh
that's nice i like that i like that you're getting um do you
have any extra rewards uh i don't think so doesn't look like
it Gun 13, huh?
I'll stick with 621.
I'm like, great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Me and my little bros.
You didn't just spawn camp for the protag.
You stole his cal sign too?
That's fucking right.
Shouldn't have queued up for rank, little bro.
Alright, let's fucking go, little bros.
misses we'll let the little bros take them down why waste my
bullets when we have little bro here all right little bro
you go handle that I'm gonna go straight here yeah clearly
he wasn't ready just target practice when we're done the
Boom.
There we go.
All right, you guys deal with all of that.
I'm not wasting my money.
Two targets destroyed.
Where's the next target?
That's what we're at.
You go!
You guys go, little bro!
All
right.
Double misses!
Wait, are these the bonus?
Because there's one I didn't kill here.
Don't worry.
I don't know man left behind.
That's right.
Look alive.
Keep moving, 6-2-1.
Hope you're enjoying the field trip, kid.
How is he fly?
He's literally a car.
Alright.
Hoop.
Oh my god, the double missile is so strong.
That's right.
Ain't doing shit on me, little bros.
I'm smurfing right now.
He's in a wheelchair.
That's right.
I'm smurfing.
Where's my other bro?
Where is he?
Where are you guys doing, guys?
Where are they going?
They're all dead.
I don't even know where the targets are.
They're like...
Like, I see the red, but where are...
Is it these?
Do I have to kill all of these guys?
They're trying their best.
Where are my little bros?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
He was just waiting for me.
Where are you guys waiting for?
Oh, that's cool.
Anyway, poop.
I mean, that's cool, but I'm here already.
Maybe you should defend it a little better, guys.
Boop.
Wait, I skipped them?
No!
Where's the boss?
Oh my god, there he is.
Wait, guys.
Don't stop now.
Why is he just standing there?
Why aren't you protecting the main line?
Why?
Should have played objectives.
Why did he not play the objective?
Turkey is money.
his fault for not playing objectives.
He's C9.
The red guns are going to be first over the wall.
Have fun watching from the I couldn't see him.
He was so small.
Did I?
I couldn't see him.
He was tiny.
It's okay.
It is more important, Doki.
He didn't just...
That's all I'm saying.
All I'm saying is he didn't play objective.
That's not my fault.
Okay, I can speed run this again.
Yeah, but I thought...
See, all have life bars.
He was so tiny.
To be fair, they all had life bars.
If you think about it.
I was looking at all the other life bars as well.
Alright.
Bring up overall.
Leave.
Okay, bring up overall.
Alright.
Let me bring up the overall real quick.
Alright, let me know Soundgab is best.
better.
Okay.
I could do this again.
Boom!
Missa!
Oh my god, bro, they collapsed.
Oh,
Missa is so strong.
All right.
There we go.
Can't say I considered you a pro either.
All right, here we go.
This time, extra money time.
Why are they going this way?
That's not where it is.
Oh, that is where it is.
Oh, that's where it is.
That is where it is.
I think my guy is having trouble getting there.
All right, this time I know where it is.
I know where it is this time, guys.
Boop.
Oh my god, wait, it didn't insta-die.
I'm not used to that.
All right.
There's a boss to my right.
There's another boss to my right.
Where is it?
This way?
Is this where I came from?
I don't see it.
Alright.
It is.
Across the lake.
This way?
I wish there was a little mini-map.
Oh, is it that guy over here?
Is it him?
It's pretty big.
It's a pretty big boy.
He's unaware.
He's so stupid.
Look at him.
He doesn't know I'm here.
Oh, shit!
Wait, he landed the shot.
Wait a minute.
How did he hit those?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, I was not anticipating him to hit me.
It's alright.
There we go.
Easy, money.
You know what?
Fuck these two guys, too.
Alright, maybe my crew...
Alright, maybe they already killed the other guys.
mini boss already no match for the double bazooka maybe by
the time i get there they've already killed the other guy
all right you guys got this wait where is the other guy
where is he
Where is the Mr. Burn Pickle?
Is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
There's Mr. Burn Pickle.
We're waiting for you, little bro.
We killed your other little bro.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
That's right.
Going fast ain't gonna save you, little bro.
What honor is there in serving corporations that exist only
to kill?
Because it's fun!
I go where the money takes me!
That's right, gift 3v1!
Should bribe your friends!
Oh wait, you did, but they're all dead!
We're smurfing!
Boom!
War for fun and profit!
And it pays!
Yeah, I...
That's right.
Get Smurfed on!
Little bro.
Nuke down.
Let's go.
Up we go.
Wee!
We did it guys.
Fuck us.
Thank you for chatting.
Thank you.
So easy.
look at that easiest mission of my life oh oh look at that
income too oh oh my god and I got new arms all right is this
arm better than my other arm oh assembly where are my arms
there you go Is it better?
Oh, it is.
Is it?
It's thicker.
Is it better, guys, or is it worse?
I can't tell.
I mean, numbers up, but the numbers down.
They're heavier?
That's fine.
For detailed stats?
Okay, attitude, recover, altitude.
Boost speed.
I have less of that.
Total load.
Total weight.
It would be better for my bazookas.
Alright.
I need stronger arms to hold these parts.
Alright, next mission.
Destroy the weaponized mining ship.
Sorry, I don't melee anyway.
I don't think I have melee, right?
I don't even have melee in my build.
It's just bazookas.
That's my melee.
It's bazookas and missiles.
No melee.
Just big explosions.
Big explosion go boom.
That's how I like it.
Just big boom.
And meleeing with explosions.
I don't even have...
Yeah, I can't kick yet, apparently.
I don't have the skills to kick yet.
I haven't learned that.
I haven't killed enough babies to figure it out.
I up the volume a bit more.
Soundgap, let me know if it's better.
Alright, destroy the weaponized Maya ship Shrider.
Key military acid.
Yeah?
This one's a request from the Archibus group.
And this request comes from Schneider.
An Archibus security.
Dan Schneider?
The mission will take place in the Bonadilla dunes of
Western Belias.
Our coral inventory.
The investigation there is being blocked by the Strider, a
Rubicon Liberation Front mining ship.
You are to destroy it.
Me?
A Strider is a mobile resource base that was extensively
weaponized by the Liberation Front.
Call it the crowning glory of their efforts to militarize
into an anti-corporate force.
How dare they?
Corporations forever.
A giant laser cannon connected directly to the main
generator.
hurt the big small company.
Which is powered by auxiliary sub-generators.
These should be your first targets.
This concludes the briefing.
Good luck.
Alright, let's go.
Is there any extra bonus enemies for this one?
Do all of them have bonus enemies?
I don't know.
Oh, destroy the wasteland mining ship.
Yeah, leave the giant small company alone.
How dare they bully the mega small corpse?
Time for a little self-promotion, 621.
Smash the Strider and Archibus HQ.
Okay, not this one.
I feel like the bonus mission, you have to find them, right?
Like, it doesn't tell you if there is.
It just, like, it shows up.
Because I didn't see it on, like, the area.
all right oh my by myself i forgot how that's just like i
squatted up i played in the i dueled with someone and now i
don't know how play solo was now i realize solo queue
fucking sucks
oh there it is that giant thing in the in the distance
wait how do i do scan again i don't remember what g it is
key is the scan button oh it was me oh shit wait stop oh
fuck okay oh my god how do i heal i didn't know
here comes the laser
holy shit he's so far i'm like fucking running across like
doing a against the current.
Am I doing it?
I'm shooting it.
Oh, it's here.
I try to get like the anchor.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
Confirmed.
Strider leg compromised.
It's going down.
We get the other leg?
Oh my god!
Oh!
Okay, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay!
I'm done!
Because I'm was not okay.
I was like, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I thought I was like, I survived the first impact.
Look, I survived the first impact and I thought I was okay.
I was like, oh my God, I'm unstoppable.
I'm so tanky.
Right, now we've got a foothold to get on the deck.
Grab one and get to work on the sub-generators.
Got footholds?
Where's the general room?
Oh, it's on top.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to get up.
Oh, fuck.
How do I get on top?
Not...
Oh, I can rest here.
Okay.
Alright.
I did it.
I climbed.
There we go.
Woo!
all right i'm okay i'm okay everybody don't worry i'm so
safe i feel so safe
that's right i'm coming for you oh shit am i though oh i'm
following I'm falling.
I'm falling.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, there's one of them.
Is that not one of them that I have to hit?
Oh, shit.
That's why I got you now.
Wait, is that not?
Oh, I have to hit the front.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Did you get me?
Jokes on you.
I dodged it!
Jokes on you!
I'm safe.
I'm so safe.
Where's the other generator?
Right in front of me.
Where's the last one?
Right below.
me?
How does he do it?
Oh, it's literally right below me.
Oh.
All right.
Generator get.
Okay.
That has to be how I get on top.
Boop.
I'm coming for you.
i see your little eye oh my god wait i thought they said i
thought oh wait wait a minute oh okay i'm falling i'm
falling okay he's charging it but he can't get me
that's working right Peekaboo!
Oh my god.
Maybe I should not have Peekaboo.
Maybe I should not have...
Maybe that was a bad idea.
Peekaboo?
Okay.
We ain't got this.
We got the cheese.
Hey, if it works, it works!
Oh, shit!
Oh, whoa,
whoa, whoa!
See, I'm slaying it.
He's gotta stop eventually, right?
See, look, look, I'm getting there, I'm getting there!
how yeah
how could she how does she do it guys what a great question
how is she doing this what how is
that not hit Does it only work if it's like when it's about
to fire or some shit?
Oh, there you go.
They'll never expect a peekaboo strat.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That's right.
One final blow.
Easy.
We did it.
Target destroyed.
Yummy, yummy.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
It won't happen again.
This time.
Oh, shit.
Don't run away.
Run away.
Cool guys don't look at explosions.
Look at that.
See, this is why cool guys don't look at explosions.
Oh, fuck!
I got the accident going the other way.
The boss says, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Look at that.
It's that easy.
That was a giant-ass boss.
Duel, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Congrats on being the largest enemy from stuff has ever
made.
that hard how does she do it i know right how does how did
she do it i mean i think it was super chat i think thank you
i released the side of the not yet not yet i think it was
super chat thank you thank you so easy make
your acquaintance v2 snail i understand you want to join
operation wall climber yeah you do realize looking for a new
job as you know your place you may be a dog sitter the
answer is no what i'm not qualified but look at my
references you call my references they can vouch for me i
know they sort of sound like me but they're they're my old
bosses you'll see just give us the chance just a small dog
in the big world
Let's see how they both perform.
I know, so rude.
I think I can make it.
I can't believe it.
He thinks I'm not qualified.
Did he see my stats?
Did he see my KDA?
Bro, but my KDA, bro.
Raven, your work on the Strider deserves commendation.
I am thrilled to have issued you the request allow me to
introduce myself i am the archivist group's mercenary
liaison v8 peter at your service saw me get squid i think
i'll enjoy doing business with you see you enjoy doing
business for me hey love thank you super chat thank you
thank you so ac6 is actually in the same engine as elder
ring and all the ac assets are actually built to scale so
when people ported the stride into elder it covered hat
that's crazy That's like crazy.
I'm surprised we're able to load all those polygons.
You know the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, how's the sound so far now?
Is it better?
Oh, I have a new training mission.
Okay, assembling an AC.
Uh, it's probably by all mine.
Um, training, double trigger boosters, mobility.
Alright, what training is this?
Oh, free part?
Uh.
I mean, we already know that.
Double trigger suddenly uses can destroy weapons that are
suitable.
Alright.
And it's just me.
Oh, I'm a fast boy.
It's like Maga in Overwatch.
I'm literally playing Maga right now.
Okay.
The mobility is great in place by its overall weight.
And a type...
Oh, cool.
A double blank.
That's right.
Can't catch me.
I'm too fast.
Uh, installed.
It greatly influenced the rest of the assembly.
Um, hold space.
I mean, that's what I've been doing, right?
That's right.
You're too fast.
Too slow.
Q to use the left shoulder.
Oh, that's the misses.
You're too slow.
go i
should give me the the range thing too yeah
uh hold use q oh is equipped with wait how do i do the okay
you see it's equipped with four range weapons why would i
ever use the control for it
that's fucking right is that cannon on your shoulder you
just have happy to see me.
That's right.
You'll never expect this.
There you go.
Uh, simulation complete.
Alright, I got...
Ooh, new part.
And I got the...
This part, and I got that part.
Okay.
I don't even know which part that's from.
Is it this?
Is it better?
Is the new part better?
There's too many numbers, gosh.
Much better?
Alright, we'll go with that.
And then I assume this is the new part.
Ooh, close range assist.
Oh, but bad for long range, though.
What about the FCS?
The numbers, what do they mean?
Yeah, I'm not a close.
range.
Am I close range?
Have I done close range?
A lot.
Yeah, I was going to say, isn't it bad for my missiles?
Oh, I don't need energy generator, though.
I feel like generator.
Yeah.
I'm mid-range.
Oh, that's true.
I am mid-range.
But it's like my long range is like really, really bad.
Bazooka's mid-range?
Okay, we'll try it.
What about this?
What about the generator?
It's worth it.
Now, this is the old one.
This is the new.
You can see it's old because it looks like a fucking PC from
1990s.
It looks like PC monitor from the 1990s.
You know giant ass ones.
This one you can tell is newer.
This one looks like a monitor from the 1990s.
Alright,
we're good.
Alright, we're good.
Alright, we got to do the other training.
Alright, what is this?
Jump, quick boost.
What the fuck?
Okay, what the fuck was that weapon?
Okay, jump, use left shoulder.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, what the fuck?
I don't even know what weapons I'm using right now.
What the fuck was that?
Weapons fall into three category.
Kinetic, explosive, and energy.
Okay.
The riot was definitely an energy gun.
Yeah, oh my god, that shit went.
Boom.
Does it go multiple?
Oh, it does.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, the kinetic goes multiple.
Use right.
Hold.
Oh, I can charge it.
Okay, that's good.
I just don't like the little delays for it.
It feels really slow.
Boop.
Alright.
Yeah, this one feels like really slow.
What current of enemies slightly reducing the damage to
take?
Try attacking at close range or switch to explosive.
So...
I mean, that was my explosive one.
Boom!
Alright, am I recharged this yet?
There we go.
It's just slow.
The weapons charge so slow.
Yeah.
The weapons he has is so slow.
The cannon goes crazy, though.
cannon missile all right which one is that oh that's a laser
hand oh it only gave me the laser handgun fuck that missile
all the way all right operation wall climber assist assault
on rubicon liberation uh front stronghold and destroy the
juggernaut heavy mobility mobile artillery with friendly
crap extra rewards based on number oh okay i just got more
kill more money this request comes straight from archivist
headquarters they want you to assist with a mission the
corporations are calling operation wall climber all right
this is v2 snail leader of the vesper second squant i will
share the briefing for this mission this is an operation of
my own design considered a privilege to be called to
participate you will be attacking the wall a key trickier
most fortified by the royal guard the walls the rabble have
formed a defensive line comprised of artillery and empty
squads we're gonna tear down the walls they make your way to
the top of the wall 9 9 weapons oh no no no no
in this mission, infiltrating through a separate route.
However, be aware that Baalm has also taken a crack at the
wall only for their vain glorious hopes to be dashed.
Do try not to die like a dog out there.
NANI Na You, Loopsilongs.
Bana, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
A na, na, na, na, na, no, no, no, no.
NANI-NAN, Luke Palones.
The Wall.
I don't know a little bit of the German version.
Oh yeah, sound guy.
Is the sound okay now?
I don't know if I adjusted it the last time.
Commence mission.
We'll start by clearing the way for Archibus.
Take out the Gatling cannons protecting the city and the
Bouse Tetrapod MT further in.
There's heavy fire coming from up top.
6-2-1.
Keep an eye out for cover.
You'll never climb the wall.
That's right.
I'm gonna climb the wall!
Now that you said I can't do it, I'm definitely gonna do it.
Holy shit!
Sorry, I stood still.
I keep standing still for some reason.
I should explore the left side.
people there
that's right now i definitely want to climb the oh my god
i'm getting up i'm getting fucked up oh my god okay i forgot
they have that stupid shield thing
all right i got a little too cocky i started standing still
so i'm gonna say Explore the left side.
What's there on the left?
Whoops.
Ooh.
I'm not aware.
Oh my god.
Who's shooting me?
Holy shit.
Alright.
Okay, I'm just gonna dodge this.
The wall.
It's okay.
I want to say to explore the left a little bit more.
What do we have on the left?
All right, leaving mission area.
There's nobody here.
Oh, is it that guy?
That guy over there?
Or is it that guy over there?
There's a lot of guys.
Yeah, what are you going to do about it, huh?
That's where I missed me.
The more people I kill, the more money I get.
Oh, ha ha ha!
Missed me again!
Oh shit.
Oh my god, wait, he hit me.
Oh, there's a dead guy to loot?
Okay, wait, give me a sec.
There's so many people have to dodge right now.
Oh, there it is, there it is.
Alright, give me a sec, I'm desecrating this body.
I'm telling you, man, you gotta give him this shit.
Michigan a chance.
He's different from the suits at HQ.
Look, I know he's an asshole, but he's looking up for us,
you know?
Almost like we got family here, eh?
But man, if there's anyone deserves punching up, it's the
freaks who sent us on a suicide mission.
You picked a good day to go AWOL.
What should I?
Aw.
Just before his death.
Oh, seven.
Oh my god.
He's like chasing me right now.
He really wants to get me.
He's trying to get me right now.
Oh shit.
I have to get the big boys here.
Oh shit!
Run one!
Okay, I'm gonna try and get the big boys first.
All right, these guys are so annoying.
I gotta kill them first.
The wall's gonna give it to you.
All right.
Wait, I know a cheese.
Watch this.
Oh my god, wait, he dodged it.
Wait, wait a minute.
That's not supposed to happen.
it when he dodged it wait my cheese oh my god keep hitting
it okay wait wait wait wait
wait oh fuck oh shit oh shit go there you go my turn to stun
you that's fucking right boom that's right dodge this oh
shit dodge this oh my god not you how did you get there
that's right dodge this little bro access the bulkhead and
break into the wall all right accessing
burned you're inside the wall be prepared for close quarters
combat boy i'm inside the wall all right last to repair kit
that's right didn't expect this did you do you read me this
is v4 rusty you're fast guess you're sharper than they say
i'll have to step up my own game Oh, I didn't expect the
fucking surprise bazooka.
All right, where's our little friend?
Ah, you think there's backup?
Why do you think no one's coming?
Backup's dead.
Oh, that's so funny that you think there's backup, little
bro.
Oh, you live.
For now.
There you go That's so cute.
There's no reinforcements.
I killed the reinforcements There should be a lift nearby.
Oh, the target is close.
All right, up I go I'm one of the good guys It's like for
democracy or something right?
Capitalism is part of democracy.
So technically I'm fighting for freedom them USA USA USA
oh we got resupply
yeah oh my god nice that's good his last food he's like it's
time all right guys i'm gonna give him his final food i'm
back that's the give him this final the final bits left in
his can all right resupply i gotta resupply he gotta
resupply all right here we go where's my where's my duo
oh shit is that my duo Look, I see.
I told you I have friends.
No more solo queue.
Hey, Rusty.
Oh, my God.
He has grasshopper legs.
Oh, shit.
That's a big boy.
You're ready to climb the wall.
I'm ready to climb the wall.
99 new balloons.
Oh, my God.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready to climb.
Oh, shit.
I'm trying to heal.
I panicked you, he hit me!
Oh my god, I actually spammed healed when he ran me over
because of that one enemy.
I started healing because I thought I was gonna get like
fucking...
I thought I was actually gonna get like instant healed.
I was like, if I heal out of it, I should be fine.
Bro, the wall's gonna slam me.
Oh my god, keep hitting the armor.
Rusty, I'm trying!
But he keeps turning around!
There we go.
Okay, to be fair, he, like, turned around.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Oh.
Oh my god, he's fucking turning around again.
Where's Rusty?
Where did Rusty go?
Wait, Rusty, where did you go?
Rusty!
Hey, Rusty!
Rusty?
What happened to the plan?
Bro, he turns around!
Fucker!
I have an idea.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he's a lot smarter than I expected.
How does I hit the armor?
Really?
There we go.
Bazooka!
Boom!
That's right.
Right behind.
Bazooka!
I got a little too cocky there.
He put himself in reverse.
He tried to run me over in reverse.
I was like, what's he got to do?
Turn.
He's got to turn around.
Confirmed.
Juggernaut destroyed.
I got him.
I told you.
Goodbye.
He knows?
It won't matter.
I've taken that contingency into account.
How did he know?
I thought I changed my voice just.
Do I not sound like his old pal?
He's like, whoa, buddy.
Why does your voice sound so different?
And also, why did you get that new paint job?
I thought you were never...
I thought your old paint job was dead.
dedicated to your wife.
Why does it look like that now?
And is that ads?
Is that the Nike sponsor on your mech?
He didn't believe my visa.
What do you mean?
My ID looks just like me.
Don't keep me outsmarted by an enemy.
Must be a day that ends in Y.
Thank you, the super chat, Mr. Broken Bomb.
Thank you, thank you.
He's like...
He knows what I am.
You know, he was like...
Rusty's just like, bro, you sold out, man.
The old Raven would never sell out.
We're war buddies now.
I think I should tell you something.
What?
During Operation Wall Climber.
Rusty?
The Archibus was planning to sacrifice you.
Yeah, but I didn't.
I was to use independent mercenaries to clear the way so
that the Vetspers could step in and take over.
How dare they do?
that instead you took the wall the higher-ups are going to
remember you now that's right I tore down the wall my man
that's right how dare our corporations will try to hire
independent mercenaries I can't believe they would try to
hire contractors how fucking dare them Rusty I would never
I'm your boy Raven always happen Those goddamn corporations,
bro.
Not me.
Always raven.
Couldn't be me.
Uh-huh.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's right.
Never do such a thing.
This message is sponsored.
Alright.
Thank you for giving this wonderful game of crab you may
have an easier time using the hard lock on versus boss fight
thank you those super chat king thank you thank you always
forget the hard lock all right uh let's see that hover there
space to hover okay all right why is it not hovering
Bro, hover!
Oh, you had to hold...
Oh, there we go.
I had to, like, double tap or some shit.
That was weird.
Because I didn't hover it.
Yeah, I had to double tap it.
Alright.
Charge attacks fire from...
Okay.
Charge attack this.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, is this meta and PvP?
Yeah, this has to be double tap.
See it.
All right.
Use left hand, right, multi-lock.
Go.
Hover!
Come here.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Why won't you hover?
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
We did it.
We hovered.
I tapped too fast.
The all I do is hug the skybox.
and spam missiles.
That sounds absolutely terrible.
Doki got an AC paint shop looking like a pre-production car
graph.
Jeez, Dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Should we... Oh, wait.
We didn't even give me... You didn't even give me the hover.
Unless they include...
What the fuck is that?
What even was it?
Was it this gun they gave me?
Developed but play video.
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is bigger missile.
Wait, was that bigger missile?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's a kinetic thing.
It's a bubble gun.
This is called a bubbly gun?
This?
Is that better than my other missile?
It is bigger, boom.
Do I get it?
Is it worth getting it?
I have two bazookas.
Oh, this?
What the fuck am I looking at?
I feel like I don't know.
It's not really a big boom.
I'm going to get the grenade launcher.
That's bigger boom.
I'm getting double big boom.
Wait, what's this?
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, that's when he couldn't climb.
The giant tank shit.
Oh, is that the hover?
Is that even good on...
Which is better?
The tank or...
Or hover?
Or should I keep the old ones?
Quad legs?
Is that quad legs?
Or is that...
Are you talking about the tank?
Which one's better for my build?
My bazooka grenade launcher build.
Tetrapod over tank?
Spotter legs?
This?
Quad just because they're faster?
Are you gonna spam missiles with...
is way better for big boom all right we'll try to tank i'm
gonna try to tank for the big boom i'll buy both and then
we'll try it out i even need to change my let's see which
one did i buy i think it was this my big boom is that my big
boom that's my big boom right yeah that's big boom
I will try a tank first.
Oh my god, my decals.
Okay.
Oh, wait, my decals are in the proper space.
And then, do I need to change my head?
We haven't bought head parts yet for a while.
Should we buy a new head?
I don't even know which is good.
What head should we get?
Is this one?
This one's all up.
Oh, I have more ad space.
That's true.
VP?
I don't know.
Grab the VP.
Top one from Armor.
It's right by System Recovery.
It has more ad space.
Guys, I'm talking about like...
I'm not talking about ad space, guys.
I'm not...
You can put more ads on that.
Guys, I'm talking about, like, survivability, not ad space.
We should get this one, then, right?
I don't have this one.
What is the body?
Oh, I can't afford a new body.
Oh, save up for a new body later.
Oh, we need the...
But, Toki, think about the exposure, though.
There we go.
That's my new head.
Alright.
That should be good.
Doing that training.
One more training.
It's my...
It's Goonbot.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Holy shit.
All right.
Oh, reloading.
That's right.
I'm a flying tank.
Oh, I can drift.
Tab, boost movement on.
Quick boost.
Oh, I can drift.
What's the fucking tab?
Oh, my God.
What's scarier than the normal tank?
A flying tank.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
I'm reloading.
Oh my god, I'm reloading.
Holy shit, thanks so much.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm trying to drift.
I'm not, I don't need a heal and a totari.
There we
go.
We did it.
Guys, tank might not be it.
Guys, I think tank might not be it, guys.
I'm not doing so well with the tank.
I think we might need a fly.
We might need to be a flyer.
Just trust the power.
Alright, alright.
We'll run one.
Tank Doki.
Wait, does Sound Guy say any...
Oh, Sound Guy didn't say anything.
But also, I remember someone said bring it up a little more.
So, I'll bring up just a little bit more.
Okay.
I'm ready.
We'll try Tank Doki up.
Uh, recover at least five combat logs from MT-Rex.
Missile mission must be completed.
within the time limit.
Where's Sound Guy?
We're gonna see when we need him.
Where did he go?
Let me double check.
Uh...
Sound Guy, don't go!
Wait, I have a new missile?
I didn't even check what it was.
There's so many names.
No, not this one.
Oh, is it this one?
Oh, but it seems like it does less.
Holy shit, it took so long.
Yeah, I like my old one.
Alright, mission.
Mission must be completed within time limit based on the
logs recovered.
Okay, I need more.
Alright.
Got a job for you, 621.
Another job.
One of the Balaam companies has put in a request.
Yeah, it looks slow.
That's me.
We're conducting an investigation into the Vespers.
Archibus's augmented human squad.
Currently, our focus is on their fourth squad leader.
Oh, B4 Rusty.
Okay.
Sweep the route Rusty took during Operation Wall Climber and
retrieve combat logs from the wrecks he left on his way in.
The wall is now under Archibus' control.
I'm back on the wall wait a minute this might be the worst
links I get maybe I shouldn't be pink
wait guys I make a little oopsie
guys I might have made a little oopsie how do I climb the
wall I'm a tank oh thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it's too Tank might not be built for this, but
it's true that I'm committed now.
I said we'd run, we do one run.
Time to take a break from shooting up the place.
Maybe, but still take.
Guys, do you think this place is wheelchair-friendly, guys?
Don't worry.
Tanks are well known to be able to climb walls.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Yeah.
Commence mission.
Search the nearby wrecks for combat logs, recording
engagements with V4 Rusty.
Oh, I see one.
Don't worry.
Percent.
Huh?
We've got company!
No.
Oh my god!
no we don't that's what we're looking for 621 i'll analyze
it on my end all right log in today's the fcs was operating
at maximum capacity and yet it was unable to track the enemy
it's completely overwhelmed by rusty speed this is clearly
uh a one-sided engagement
oh my god this actually might this actually might have been
the worst
I might have actually picked the worst one to run the tank
build up.
Where the fuck are the others?
Where did you kill the others?
Oh, I see them.
They're not...
No, they're not...
Did they not retrieve it?
I pressed F.
This is not looking good anymore.
I pressed F, guys.
Alright.
in the wall we found in galia and it's going to drop sooner
than later we just can't harvest as much coral um as we used
to and what little do we get the corpse squeezed out of us
they know we need to raise the mealworms how many children
must we watch starve some more evidence on what the coral
situation not enough
okay there's two more i see two down there
oh my god this tank is so slow
All right.
Okay.
All right, there we go.
Video record extracted from a wreck allows one to discern
the assembly of Rusty's AC steel haze.
The steel haze appears to be assembled from a Schneider high
mobility frame equipped with weapons that allow for swift
agile action.
Notably, Rusty appears to favor kinetic weaponry that Vesper
members would normally not use.
I think I Okay, maybe missile is not it maybe tank is not it
just just a maybe
Just a little maybe
There we go a little friendly damage
All right Tractor from appears to be a conversation between
allies we can't be the top Vespers were as good as dead.
At least he's off duty.
She's a little bro, she's a little bro, little sister.
Oh my god, there's a little bro and a little sis.
She doesn't deserve to be out here on the battlefield.
She can still love and be loved and have a family.
Oh, not anymore.
Oh, his last one.
What are you doing here?
Oh, shit.
Hey, guys.
I'm just chilling.
Having a vacation.
There we go.
That's right.
I can fly.
Boop.
Okay, now I can analyze.
Bitwreck are extracted from the wreck containing leftover
data from an attempt to communicate with Rusties during
combat.
I know.
How could you?
I know who you are.
I've seen Uncle's files.
At least tell me why.
Oh my gosh.
He knows who I am.
He knows what to do.
you are guys he knows he knows what you are there's any more
wrecks oh there is there's one down here oh there's two down
here me
oh hello well me comes Erlon world technology, you must hit
it.
Oh, shit.
Just help us out if you engage her.
The mission comes before everything else.
Oh, shit, really?
Okay, give me a sec.
The mission comes before anything else.
All right, got it.
The last one, examine.
Um, the commands received by a craft prior to its
destruction.
No data regarding offensive or evasive maneuvers.
Oh, is that the girl?
Oh, that's Lil Cis!
Appears to the pilot of this craft and immediately pulled
the emergency eject lever at the start of the operation.
Oh, where's Lil Cis?
Lil Cis, where are you?
I'm trying!
Is she alive?
Wait, but I gotta kill little sis!
No!
Is she alive or not?
Does she matter?
Oh, only 40k?
I had to kill little sis!
She lives.
Two new messages.
Oh, she had a combat log?
Alright, it's time.
I gotta kill little sis.
I got some decent intel on V4.
I'll report this to Commander Michigan.
Additionally, I'll introduce myself.
Gun 6 red.
G6.
Privileged to be among Balaam's best.
Even if I am stuck whipping you independence into shape.
You know what this voice actor reminds me of?
The Starcraft.
Starcraft troopers.
Like a G6.
Alright.
Yeah, the Marines.
It sounds just like the Marines in Starcraft.
Granting authorization to perform AC OS upgrades.
Additional.
All mind hereby invites you to the arena combat this sounds
like the robot AI in Starcraft.
This is a virtual combat simulator designed to support the
development of registered mercenaries.
It also serves as a benchmark to a praise Oh yeah, the siege
tank.
They do.
They sound like the siege tank.
Yeah.
We look forward to your participation.
Wait, let me play it.
Alright, yay!
Features are now available.
OS tuning and arena.
Is that the PvP?
What's OS tuning?
Upgrading improves can be contained in the... What is that?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I melee now.
I need... Oh, I have to get this in Arena?
Wait, Arena's not PvP.
Okay.
Alright, so that's the upgrade for the...
For...
For the melee, right?
Alright, this is what he sounds like.
He sounds just like that guy.
Here, this is what he sounds like.
Okay.
Literally sounds just like him
Every time I hear that Identify target Ready to roll it out
Order sir One to one Literally one to one Okay here win
arena to obtain your news chips to perform os upgrades all
right that's two like many other a member of rad a dozer
faction like many other dozers rami is earlier addicted to
coral based drugs and in this perpetually idle state it
convinced himself that he's an invincible demigod oh you
know just the usual just you know just the usual day-to-day
in armor core even should even reality intervene with a
costly defeat we forget about the setback entirely by next
day or death can the spell bell his notions all right we
just gotta make him think he's not a god by killing him I
mean true that would work we gotta fight the the crackhead
this is a 1v1 don't worry nothing's gonna happen to you the
corporal heads told us to have a one friendly 1v1 don't
worry you'll be safe You're invincible, right?
Why is this emblem a fucking foot?
Yeah.
No, we gotta end you.
Oh,
you know what?
Bro, your emblem's a goddamn foot, bro.
Did I not stun you?
I don't think I did.
Wait, does he have a shotgun?
All
right.
Ha ha.
Couldn't get me.
Just got him.
Don't worry.
I got the tank filled by my side.
That's right.
Boom.
What the fuck?
How did I miss?
There we go.
Easy.
Easiest way.
1v1 on my left boom that's right ain't no god now that's
fucking right wow all right goodbye yay i got my upgrade i
got mad stop i got his feet
mad stop got stomped all right next up in oh god he put
flames on him oh see i told you he put on your gun and make
it shoot faster no joke you're giving him what he wants a
blue collar worker who was involved in the construction of
the grid he is now dedicated to establishing symbiosis with
the quarrel and building a future for rubicon free from
planetary closure inspired by father dolmayan's ideas
able-bodied and eager but he is zealously dedicated to the
cause but he is more then the cockpit all right all right
why are we killing him oh he's a leader though never mind he
tried to start a union that's right no unions allowed I was
like he seems fine oh he started a union how dare he he
deserves to die
arena combat aptitude evaluation program All right They're
AI copies.
They're giving me practice for to take them down later We're
gonna bust a union I know I'm gonna do it again That was the
guy you 3v1 don't worry.
I'll do it again.
No wonder we 3v1 him.
We were union busters guys Wait now it's a solo operation.
Wait, this is I don't know worse where's my where's my group
where's my four stack where was my three stack
where the are you gonna do your tiny ass guns what the fuck
that's so sad oh never mind he shot a missile just now how
dare he start a union i'm gonna tank that shot my my nades
are stronger
Okay, I hit this.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I direct it!
Another Union gun!
Easy.
Target destroyed.
Concluding evaluation.
Wee!
me now oh no we're going to hell never mind they know the
things i've done all right nice yeah more chips no union for
you it's 10 shy there's the back duck thank you with a super
chat thank you thank you all right as a young boy oh g6 red
oh we're gonna kill him we're gonna kill the Starcraft man.
Red life was for a change when he saw the news broadcast of
Commander Michigan's brutal triumphs in the Jupiter War.
Red trained through blood, sweat, and tears in order to
emulate his idol, supporting his improvised siblings.
All the while, when the Balaam admission examination finally
came, he won his place in the red guns at the very moment he
stood to attention to greet the squad.
All right.
I'm ready to simulate me beating the shit out of him.
I'm getting practice, guys.
Before the real deal.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Alright.
Sir, yes, sir.
Let's see how strong he is.
Alright, he looks strong.
It gave him a longer cut.
scene.
He looks a little strong.
Oh, we're in the desert, too.
Wait, where is he?
I don't like how I don't know where he is.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he dodges.
That's cheating.
Oh, my God.
He dodges everything, too.
Holy shit!
My turn!
Okay, tank fill is like really hard for this.
Alright, when he throws this goddamn missile...
It's okay, I also have a tank, though.
Oh wait, that's easy.
Never mind.
He's fucking weak as hell.
That's right!
Can't dodge a missile, though!
Get over here!
Big boom!
Big fucking boom!
There we go.
This concludes F rank evaluation.
Well done.
See?
Easy.
Big boom time.
I let him take me down to one fourth HP, guys.
I let him do that.
All right.
Easy.
Yeah, by them hit me.
It's for the content, bro.
Incoming comms.
Oh, they saw me do a really good job.
You have surpassed rank F.
We're glad to oversee your development as a mercenary.
Oh my god, I'm getting better.
I got promoted.
all right no way that cost me money that was like a
simulation okay we should get this right the kick uh boost
kick hits you with a heavy impact by Kamani wait no which
one's the melee is there a melee
is that the melee oh I can't do that I'm on a tank you're
right Wait, I can't do...
How do I boost kick if I'm a tank, guys?
Guys, wait.
But how do I do it if I'm a tank?
Works still?
Oh, I can still ram?
Oh, okay.
We'll grab it.
Okay, I ram.
Alright.
Uh...
What else should we get?
It just works.
Alright.
What else do I get, guys?
I'm going to get armor.
Center.
Red damaging.
What do I get?
Repair kit.
Is there a repair kit?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, yeah.
We should grab the repair kit.
You're right.
All right.
Now I have two more points.
Oh, weapon bay.
Feature allowing children to replace with additional hand
weapons.
What does that mean?
uh switch right flip to switch oh can i put oh i can have
more guns
oh wait i get four bazookas wait imagine four bazooka i can
have four Big booms.
Oh my god.
You're so right.
Wait, how do I...
Okay.
Wait, how do I equip it, though?
Wait, how do I equip big booms, though?
Hello.
Where is my big booms that I was promised?
Maybe more?
I need to buy more?
Oh.
I'll buy more.
Okay, here.
Oh.
okay where's big boom is that laser no these are the
missiles these aren't big booms I need a body extra guns
like here but I do have the extra guns where is my extra
bazooka gun there's
an extra tab for shoulder weapons yeah cuz I have one I know
I have one of them but oh wait there is an extra tab wait
Oh, there we go.
All right, where's my big boom?
Okay, this one's already equipped, so it has to be this one.
Oh, there we go.
Big boom.
There we go.
Yeah.
Now I have three big booms.
All right, we got to replay.
Oh, I have more training.
Do we kill that lady?
I feel like we should, right?
Yeah, let's go kill her.
We already completed the other one.
So...
Alright, let's go kill her.
Time to kill the other big...
The other lady.
Can I just skip the combat log and go straight to...
Straight to the...
um straight to her guys
yeah but you still oh i still need to clear the oh okay i
still need a clear uh get at least one log okay sorry i was
like i had to i got a message so i was just like who's this
person yeah i was i had to look at it
uh okay i need killer fast okay just need Five.
All right, that's fine.
So I just get three.
As long as I get three, and then I'm going to go straight to
Killinger.
Six, two, one.
You should be used to Rubicon by now.
Time to take a break.
All right, skip it.
It's too late.
I'm all... I've invested all in a tank.
I'm already all in.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
just skipping all of them so i can go straight there
no you don't that's not five minutes that's like four
minutes
all right now where's the other guy oh i got hit by one more
oh what the fuck
Who's the other guy?
Okay, get this thing for me first.
Alright.
I don't want to use it.
Wait, why can't I use it?
Wait, why can't I use the missile gun?
I can use the missile, but I can't use the other one.
It's just swapping my gun.
Yeah, but how do I activate it?
Yeah, but my gun to use it is...
The thing is, the other...
The Q one, wait.
Oh!
No, but like, my Q was my missile.
But, if I swap it to Q, so do I just...
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
Oh, no, I don't think I'm going to kill him.
I get it now.
I get it.
I understand.
The double.
Okay.
Oh, I get it now.
Me understand.
Alright, I think I have to kill her in two minutes.
Shot me All right You should come in here now
That's me All right It'll just hold us up if you engage her
The mission comes before everything else
That's me.
I gotta kill you in.
I gotta kill you, girl.
But where did you go?
Nope.
I don't think so.
I'm just gonna heal right here.
Boom!
There we go.
We did it.
Give me your combat log.
Oh, too bad for you.
Oh, where's the combat lie?
I was promised a lie.
But you guys lied to me.
I killed her for no reason.
Oh, I got it?
Oh, I'll get back up here.
Oh, I get it automatically.
Oh, I see.
Oh.
Just because.
What's up here?
I already finished it.
I got five.
Yay!
Job done.
Got everything.
I get it now.
Wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee.
Two big pools.
Three big pools.
Yeah, that's right.
I already got like nine before.
Or ten?
I got ten log.
Yeah, I just got five.
Mission complete.
What about four big booms?
That's true.
I could get four big booms.
Yay!
Extra money!
Alright, you're right.
Do I have enough money?
I can!
Okay.
It was like this.
right where's the other big boom is this it's a shotgun it's
not that one or what's the other one did i have it for that
hand rifle handgun shotgun machine gun do i not have it
do i already own it i'm pretty sure i don't i didn't buy the
that actually buy it already?
Oh, I do.
I have it.
Nice.
Is this?
Oh, yeah.
Let's go.
Four big booms.
No infantry boss, arsenal number two, and determine why it
went silent.
Got a job for you.
621.
Con liberation front.
Here's the briefing.
Oh, that's a guy killed.
That's a union bus there.
Okay.
We believe you are...
Perhaps we can even work together.
I want you to investigate Bounce Arsenal number two.
A major MT factory in the Baleus region.
They're under union bus.
Bounce operations sells to anyone, but they've been
essential to maintaining our firepower.
Are we scabs?
I like to be called independent contractors.
I work just as hard as a union member.
All right, here we go.
I'm ready.
My four big boons.
Some advice before you go, 6-2-1.
Yeah, no aside, the moon, I'm- whatever pays me the most,
I'm there.
All right, here we go.
I got this.
All right, the tank's here.
Hawkeye!
That's not a good sign.
That's where the flying tank is here.
It's not a good sign when he doesn't pick up anything,
though.
Oh, this seems very boss-like.
Too quiet.
Way too quiet.
Try not to be in a tank, guys.
You think maybe being a tank was a bad idea?
Oh.
Watch out, 6-2-1.
Whoa Hey, not cool not cool
What the fuck
What oh my god, he's invisible
Where did he go Decoded comms Was that mech behind 621 it's
not fair.
I'm so slow
All right, off I go.
It's just what, it must have been a fluke, right?
It's got you in its sights.
Oh my god, never mind.
Do not walk into it.
All right.
It might have been a bad idea to, like, run straight at it.
I just...
Oh my god.
my god use your scanner mark your targets to undermine their
tricks
what the wait who are you
wait what oh my god i gotta heal there you go whoops Keep
going.
Stay sharp.
Oh, I'm on reverse now.
That's fine.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
Let me fix that.
There we go.
Don't...
I'm reversed for some reason.
Um...
There we go.
I fixed it.
This is fine.
According to the blueprint, there's a massive water
reservoir deep inside the arsenal.
If there's anything waiting for us, that's where it'll be.
Anybody over here?
Knock knock.
Creep, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
That's right.
I can reverse drift.
Oh my god, behind me.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, oh, oh, where am I?
Oh, I'm over here, apparently.
Oh my god, I'm fucked up.
I'm trying, he's whipping!
This man has a whip!
There's no way I don't hit those.
Repair kit remaining.
How did he dodge that?
Boom!
Wait, what?
Okay.
Oh my god.
These guys are so annoying.
I'm so slow!
I'm trying to get them!
This is the wrong robot for this mission.
There we go.
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
Oh my god, he fucking disappeared.
I see you!
You really need the legs.
I need a resupply stack.
Oh, no more repair kit.
Hey, you did tell him to go.
This is a little bad.
Is that a cruel response?
621.
Get down and take a closer look.
Oh my.
Yeah, I might have should have gone with the hover legs.
Alright, here we go.
Wee!
Slow down about it.
It's water.
Oh.
Not good.
Does not look so good.
Oh, this looks like a pot.
party.
Looks like I'm about to come to a party right now.
And no repair kits, by the way.
Unknown craft.
Or is it?
Above me!
Oh my god, this is not good, actually.
We need four!
Oh, guys.
Oh,
goodbye.
Oh, goodbye.
Guys, I don't think tank filled was meant for this
particular map.
I don't think.
Don't worry, I got this.
I believe.
make tank build work.
Oh, that's right.
I will make tank build work.
Yeah.
I just got my heels back.
This is not wheelchair accessible, guys.
I will have to talk to management about this.
I might need to talk to management.
This isn't wheelchair accessible.
This is
All right.
Up me.
She's lying.
Okay.
Oh my god, I see you.
I fucking knew it.
There we go.
Okay.
I fucking see your stupid shots
that's fucking right I ain't stupid I can see you go big
boom I
told you I can adapt there
you go boom Oh, I wanted to ram him.
See, I told you.
Easy.
This wasn't a simple check-in after all.
Head back and rest up 621.
Look at that.
I told you, Tank Doki will win.
I told you.
Let's go.
Look at that.
I saw, oh my god, that's a lot.
Maybe two big booms not it.
No, it's the repair.
You're right.
It's just the repairs.
I might I might have I just used too many repair kits
Take jokie always wins Long time no see Walter looking good
for a change I See you've got a new augmented human What
happened to 617 and the rest their jobs I did what I have to
do
huh so how's the newcomer doing adequately but gen 4
augmentation what if i can have six big booms imagine guys i
found the data our friends left behind there's something
promising in the watchpoint
six big booms
that's armor core seven they'll give us six arms
We placed my legs with bazookas.
Imagine, guys.
I see your back, 621.
About the coral well that was found at Bouse Arsenal number
two.
That was just a trip coming from an underground vein.
And then the legs.
What if I could attach bazookas on my legs?
One more thing.
I've sent you your next job.
Alright.
This one isn't from the corpse.
or the liberation front not you'll see when you check the
briefing oh what could it be what could it be i finished oh
i finished all of them i want to do a train you know one
more we set one more training oh what do you attach it on
the head what if on the head the bazooka head all right
during real missions you can expect any reinforcements and
other changes to the The test of advanced mercenaries and
ability to adjust to a wide range of combat.
Wait, this is my big boom.
Wait, this is my mech.
Why are we on my mech?
There we go.
Easy.
Oh, shit!
That's right, I'm afraid of you.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, he does so many booms.
Quick swap!
Oh, yeah?
Akit, I'll damage you.
Boy, actually, I'm just shooting the shields.
I just noticed that.
Okay, but, like, what if?
What if I start?
I'm trying to ram him.
Okay, that didn't work.
I can't fly a bird.
him I'm too tanky wait unless I have the high ground now
wait I can't fly above him there we go I told you guys oh
shit wait hello I didn't even notice you all
right I have repairs.
I ain't afraid of you.
You're gonna have to slow down soon.
That's right.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck is so fast?
Quick swap.
That's where I can take it all.
I ain't scared.
I'm all tank.
Get out of here.
Is that it?
Ha!
Easy.
Training.
Congratulations on your certification.
My big boom is stronger than your tiny gun.
You have proven your skills by completing the entire combat
training.
Registration number RB23.
Call sign.
Raven.
That's me.
All mind anticipates excellent performance.
Yay!
Okay, I got the advanced mercenary.
You want me to try to quad legs?
All right, we'll try it for one round, one mission.
All right, attack the watchpoint.
Eliminate the SG.
Yeah, now I'm a professional.
I got certified, guys.
I'm a certified armor core mech.
Eliminate the SG squad and the watchpoint destroy the device
in the control center.
All right, we'll try.
One round with Hover.
This is a rather personal request from a friend of mine.
It concerns a certain facility, a watchpoint.
Once it regulated the underground flow of coral.
Now it serves to monitor the dormant veins.
I want you to attack it.
Your objective will be to destroy the sensor valve at its
core.
The watchpoint is kept secure by SG, the planet-side PCA
force.
Which means it's too hot for the corporations to be seen
there.
Okay.
We're flying strictly solo on this one.
I mean, I've been solo queueing this entire time.
They gave me one 3 stack and one duo queue.
And my duo queue, like, left mid-game.
They're like, GG's.
GG's, support diff, and then left.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?
This is my rank-up game, bro.
What the fuck?
Oh, I forgot to buy a new chest.
Okay, let's try the hover.
Wait, does it give me my booster again?
Alright.
Let's try the hover legs.
You'll be going in under cover of darkness.
Be ready for anything.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I got this.
First try on the hover legs.
Let's go.
What can go wrong?
Don't worry, they can't see me.
I'm camoed.
Look at that.
Where am I?
I only see two floating guns.
Four floating guns.
Where could she be?
Look at what, Doki.
Yeah.
Can't see me.
I'm all camels.
We...
Who's gonna see me?
Not this guy.
He dead.
Oh my god!
Okay, maybe I gotta start.
I gotta start.
Holy shit.
That took so much.
Oh my god.
That took a lot of damage.
Maybe I should not have done that.
There we go.
That's just that.
It'll be fine.
Oh, don't worry, I got you.
Where are you?
There you go.
Yeah.
I am a little fucked up right now.
I've accidentally tanked two shots.
That's a little bit.
Just let me...
Let's just...
How did I not hit him?
That's literally a missile.
I can see it.
I know for a fact that that's a missile right there.
Where did that AC come from?
What happened to the patrol squad?
Yeah, see?
I fucking knew it.
All units deploy for combat.
You're exposed to snipers from all quarters.
Keep moving where they'll shoot you down.
Holy shit, what?
and 30 percent oh my god how do i dodge that
how do i dodge that all right let's try it okay now that i
know you don't oh that's cool okay now i know leave no
evidence if anyone sees you handle it all right where's
gonna where's gonna dodge this all right now we know these
guys are pretty fucky not gonna lie they're unaware it's
just one ac who are they with we get these guys out of here
i don't care
okay i might have gotten a copy i could have i will say i
definitely could have like not died I could have not died.
I could have healed, but I did not think I would have died.
I really didn't think that would have killed me.
Not gonna lie.
I was very confident I'd live.
I was like, nah, I live.
Holy shit, it like honed on me.
I'm not a tank anymore.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to just, like, hovering.
I'd be like, woo!
I'm not used to that, guys.
I'm so used to, like...
I'm not so used to just taking everything.
I'd be like, yeah, I live.
But I didn't live.
Where did that AC come from?
What happened to the patrol squad?
Code 1A, all units deployed for combat.
You're exposed to snipers from all quarters.
Keep moving without shooting down.
Oh my god, did I...
Did the wall...
Did the wall save me?
Oh my god!
It pre-fired!
Bro, it's pre-firing!
It's cheating!
He's walling!
Detaining your marker data.
Proceed in the direction indicated.
I'm gonna repair bro he pre-fired he's hacking
you see that that's the watchpoints control center the
targets inside make your way in swear to god there's another
giant-ass missile I swear I'm fucking I'm walking here I'm
taking cover right now
attacking a watchpoint you're incorrigible handler Walter
Brad it looks like a Gundam dogs must I kill before you
learn oh my god is that so pitiful dog I feel sorry for you
I really do oh shit or you had a different master see what
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fucking, I'm zooming up.
We're 619 at 620.
Dead?
Which ones did I kill?
I wonder.
Don't let it bait you.
Focus.
get kicked oh my god where am I oh shit I could kick too oh
my god he keeps dodging everything guys I hate the hover I
don't think I was meant to play the hover I was definitely
not meant to play the hover guys it's time i'm bringing back
the tank
it's time to bring boring to take force the hover that's it
i'm bringing the big boys
i'm bringing it in Yeah, I see it.
I'm ready.
It's tank boy time.
I'm coming over.
Tank boy time.
That's right.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm ready
We fight down here get over here That's right He's an
independent mercenary who survived first-gen augmentation
Don't think try a six-to-one kill him before he kills you
Boom Where did he go?
That's right.
Oh my god, wait, he's fucking...
He knows whenever I want to...
It's fucking right.
Oh my god, I'm not going to do that anymore.
I'm not going to try and do a kick.
It's not worth it.
Here you make fine hounds with the right training.
Shame, you'll have to die here.
One repair kit remaining.
Come on.
You're good, let me shoot you!
You heal!
You fucker!
Oh my god, this guy fucking heals.
I remember the damage I did too.
Oh, fuck.
No repair kits remaining.
All right.
Are you serious?
Come on.
Yes!
Get down!
Take Doki for the win!
Oh, you heal, I heal.
You heal, I heal.
Boom!
Take Doki!
There we go.
Yeah, I took you, right?
Tank toky walks another day.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
I thought I was going to be TP'd somewhere.
All right.
Wait, and the mission isn't...
Why isn't the mission over?
What the fuck?
I can't...
killed him what else is in here what do you mean
oh please tell me there's a resupply over here
hello oh nice okay at least i have resupply that's fine i
got so about that
oh oh at least i have a resupply that's fine i guess i'll
all right here i go again oh oh now that seems more like a
boss fight okay just killed a mini boss here i go destroy
the device in the center
oh all right who's coming coming out it
was coming to kill me now good job 61 is it really are we
are we actually done here are we though that doesn't seem
very done oh why is it glowing red oh oh no
on.
Gladys?
Is that you?
That's me.
Have we made contact?
I am Air, a Rubiconian.
Okay.
Please, you must wake up before your consciousness.
Oh my god.
Coral flow.
Coral flow?
That's the energy.
I'm- what?
The fuck?
I'm gonna get a fucking Foxy jump scare now?
Women.
New wife.
Oh, that's me.
God, it looks so beautiful.
It's time.
Nice guy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's me.
I've identified an approaching enemy.
Oh?
What's that?
Wait, he can fly.
Wait, that's illegal.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait.
That's not fair.
What do you mean reactivating?
Oh my god!
It's an autonomous PCA craft.
all right that's right oh shit that's my big boom
all right
that's fucking right you You think your bubble's gonna stop
me?
Boom!
Oh,
shit.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What do you do?
Holy shit, he has a flame thrower!
What does...
How does he have so many shit?
That's illegal.
That's actually illegal.
That's not fair.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's so far.
Okay, it's my last repair kit.
Boom!
Oh my god, he's sick-booming me!
what
Jesus Christ oh fuck oh fuck no this is not fair
what HP that's fucking right let's go that's a fucking go
what HP in a dream you can't beat big boom big boom always
wins let's fucking go i'm hurt let's go
i'm feeling it now You beat the beller.
Tara, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My build.
I created the perfect build.
Hey, look.
Boobs.
Psycho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, as soon as a woman started talking in my head, I
locked in.
I was like, do it for her.
Go to Runa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on beating the filter boss on the first try.
Oh my god, look at me.
I'm here.
Yes, Gino.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
First try.
Let's go.
You would be here if it wasn't the nerfed fruit.
Hey, hey, hey.
I still beat him.
To be fair, oh my god.
To be fair, I also sort of like forced.
I face tanked the end because I was like, he's one.
And then I lost 3,000 HP.
Like, I did, I sort of, I might have faced ink the last,
like, 30 seconds of that fight.
Whoa, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
A wins, a win.
About Tua's first try, I have to see Armacore getting
popular again.
Husky, thank you, thank you, thank you, congrats on
defeating the second filter.
Unfortunately, the heavily nerfed filter, but filtered
nonetheless.
Mac, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Look at that.
Look at tank build!
Tank build!
Welcome to Rubicon.
Just keen rules.
God, thank you for checking.
Thank you.
So first try, guys.
It's headed straight for the central ice field.
Across the Aalian Ocean.
Like a flock of birds or a school of fish.
Coral loves company.
Uh-huh.
which means somewhere in the ice field there's a huge mass
of coral lying dormant i didn't choose to take there a
strange boy for it it chose me
thank you about super chat thank you thank you don't let it
bother you
completely vaporized to northwestern Baleus's Bay Area.
And even yet, compared to the fires of Ibis, that explosion
was hardly a spark.
yeah?
I have a favor to ask.
Oh my god, my new wife is asking me for a favor.
Until we reach the coral convergence.
All right.
I have to see where they're taking us.
Oh, yeah, that.
How this struggle over the coral ends.
I must, as a Rubiconian.
They gave me the Aoe's attack?
Which one was it?
He had so many attacks.
I lost count.
Whoa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Augmented human.
C-4621.
Entering standard mode.
Two new messages.
Hello, Mushy Mushy.
Mina.
Konnichiwa.
I've got some business to attend to.
I need to hawk some intel to the corpse and secure a backer
for our trip to the icefield.
One chop for you while I'm out.
Rest up.
And that's an order.
Alright.
I got you.
Minasai.
Konnichiwa.
I'm sorry.
A video that's rent-free in my head.
It's so good.
It's a good trip to the ice field.
We've received a job from Baylam already.
Let's take a look.
Shall we?
Yay.
Oh my god, this is goals.
Me and my wife working together in the same company.
Nothing bad's gonna happen with that.
Yeah, she's my work wife and my house way.
She ranked virtual encounters are now available in the
arena.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen.
Yeah, we don't separate our work, our work personal life at
all.
Oh, new.
Oh, nice.
Neurina.
All right, should we buy a new chest?
I feel like we haven't upgraded that yet.
Ooh.
All right.
Where is it?
It's, oh my gosh, I'm, I don't have a lot of money.
What the fuck is my, where's the fuck is the chest?
Okay.
what should i get guys what would be the best for us should
we get like maybe the most expensive one should we get the
coke vp have your chest for more hp which one's more ap go
and load way more ap it should be this then that's like or
all or this The DF-P-D-O-8.
We get that?
That's the most AP.
Yeah, that does.
Or do we get the VP?
Do we get the DF or the VP?
I say Tian?
DF?
Alright.
All right, the DF.
Yeah, heavier arms, dude.
Do I have more arms?
I don't even know.
I've...
Wait, is that new?
Should we get this?
Oh, shit.
That's a heavy, heavy arm.
We should get this, right?
The DF as well?
All right, let's grab that, and then we'll put that
together.
Assembly.
We're in the arms.
Hey, uh Yeah, oh, wait, where's my where's the boobs?
Where does the boobs part go?
We gotta fix that Holy shit.
All right, this beautiful that's a big boy That's a big
fucking boy right there.
All right, let's decals all right
Just to make sure you guys paid for the sponsor.
Put it here.
We'll put this here.
And then...
Alright, and then...
I want to move this.
How do I move this?
How do I move it?
Yeah.
Oh, we got...
Let's see it.
move and then we put
um there
you go there you go perfect all right and then uh
no not boobs um where is it
there you go you're
so you guys paid for the ad space so Making sure.
There we go.
Got it.
Alright.
I think we got everything.
This.
Alright.
Arena.
Oh, there's more places now to fight.
Alright, Independent Mercy was snuck onto Rubicon hoping to
get rich quick.
Taking advantage of the chaos brought about by the
extrapolatory corporation forays.
under nozac's economic theory the funds of others are by are
but extensions of his own resources thus he continues to
take on debt with no intention of repaying as an insides the
money was his anyway this does have a benefit allow him to
buy the latest in corporate technology as soon as hits the
market oh shit he is in credit card debt all right debt
collector here
somebody's debt all right let's try out this tanky bill i
don't think i'm dodging anything anymore debt mat he's not
even avoiding taxes he's avoiding his debt he's not repaying
his debt from all the money he's a debt collector is here oh
there's people who like hunt the bill like people who like
try to run away from paying bit uh
oh my god oh my god i have so much hp and those people who
like chase after uh people who are like avoiding their
bailers and are they like down are they actually all right
oh wait of course
Ghost cause?
You know, there's like, those reality TV shows where they
film, like, them taking, like, trying to...
Is it actually bounty hunters, too?
You know, those people that... There's a reality TV show
where... Is that actually also bounty hunter?
The reality TV show?
Bro, I did not care.
I literally stood still.
Dog...
Was it dog the bounty hunter?
The one that's self-reliant?
part to the parody of?
It's like, that's you, Doki, a bounty hunter.
Oh my god, it is!
He is the bounty hunter.
That's me!
Alright.
Nice.
I need heavier weapons, but I have a bazooka!
What's better?
What's heavier than that?
What's heavier than a grenade launcher?
I probably just found out what her job is.
I didn't realize that's what the show was called, too.
I was thinking about the show.
I can get bigger bazooka?
There's a bigger boom?
Wait, is it available now?
No way.
I can have a bigger boom?
Oh my.
God oh my I'm poor I'm broke right now okay oh my god napalm
oh there's always a bigger wait no it does less damage guys
look it does less damage I don't know guys it doesn't do as
much damage as my
my other boom does a bigger boom no oh wait this one does
bigger this one's bigger okay wait this one's bigger bigger
oh my god wait this one's bigger bigger oh my god he's mad
hey hey hey no no no no no no okay there's no food he just
wants food he's trying to get more food but there's no food
which one should i get we get the alpha i feel like we
should get the alpha right where's that big boom
javelin all right we gotta sell i don't know what should
sell though I don't know which one to sell.
The POW bunker.
Which one is that?
Yeah, but like...
Wait, is it bigger?
Oh, it's...
Is it bigger boom?
Where's the POW bunker?
Wait, which one is it?
It's double boom, guys.
Oh, left arm millet.
What does this do?
Yeah, but it's not big boom, though.
But guys.
It does a ton of damage.
It's completely worth it.
Okay, I trust you.
But what do I get rid of?
What do I get rid of, though?
I don't know what to get rid of.
Well, obviously, I'm getting rid of the rifle.
Fuck it.
Let's sell the rifles.
I don't need those, actually.
I'll get those away.
Get these filthy shit off of me.
Alright.
We'll grab
the pile of bunker.
We'll try that up.
Alright, and then...
Okay.
I have this, uh, wait, but, okay, we'll put that on, and
then,
that's the grenade launcher.
Okay, so this needs to be, uh, the grenade launcher.
Oh, I don't have enough arms for it.
Bazooka.
Yeah, I got the grenade launcher.
launcher for that.
Wait, what is my grenade launcher called?
It's the, okay, the gold chain.
Oh, okay, I think it's fine.
Uh, grenade launcher, grenade launcher, bazooka.
This is the bazooka, right?
Yeah.
Alright, we're good.
Alright, let's try this out in the arena.
Six squad leader, the Vespers, the Aribus Group's augmented
human squad.
Matterlink is a product of generation 8 which was held to be
advanced in the process to the point of rendering all
previous generations obsolete bringing about a new stage of
augmentation unfailing loyal to arabus she has a reliable
track record in the field and her conduct during missions
has established her as a risk averse problem solver all
right time to kill her okay after i stunned them i bunker
okay that was my right hand so it's my right clay
I need to stagger them to use it.
Subject AC.
Infection.
Call sign.
V6.
Materlink.
Alright, here we go.
Is there... Is there a fucking mosquito?
What the fuck was that?
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Alright.
I'm trying to remember...
Oh, it's my right click.
Okay, now I know.
That's bad.
Please stop moving around, ma'am.
Stop!
How am I supposed to kill you?
Oh my, this is bad.
Wait, this might be my worst matchup.
Wait, this actually might be my worst matchup.
Oh my god.
Too fast.
How could this be?
How could she be faster than Big Boom?
She actually is my worst matchup so far.
Oh my god.
She's too fast.
Wait, I can do this.
I can do this.
You're right.
I need more big booms.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, she just flies over me.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot that my starter is that.
Oh my gosh, I stunned her.
What the fuck?
I've tried, but she's so fast.
Okay.
She's so fast.
Oh my god.
Please get stunned.
Guys, I don't think pile.
I don't think a pile bunker is the way to go.
I think, okay, wait.
I think it's back to big boom.
Just like old times.
This is it.
I can do this.
Alright.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here!
That's right!
Big Boom always wins!
Wait, where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
Where did she go again?
Oh my god, come on!
She's so low.
No!
Oh, we are so close!
Oh!
We were so close!
Big boom, almost won!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We got this.
Oh my god, we were so close.
She dodged everything.
Activating combat mode.
Okay.
I didn't remember the ram, so not used to it.
Jesus Christ!
There we go.
Oh my god, never mind, this is my...
I want a rammer so bad!
I will make this work, guys.
I know you're like, swap builds, don't get, but this build
will work.
Speed won't deter me.
Okay, next run, next run.
Oh my god.
Oh my, okay.
Okay, I got this, guys.
Big boom forever.
Speed won't deter me.
I'll get this.
Believe in it.
I don't move my...
Someone said, like, don't move your mouse when you lock in.
But, like, I feel like I have to sometimes, because it's,
like, it doesn't land.
So, I aim without moving.
It, like, feels like it doesn't land.
Oh, my God.
He stunned me.
That fucking bitch!
the
fish i was winning and then she stunned me oh my god again
oh my god she's i was doing it i don't care i don't care if
her if she beats my type i don't care Big boob will reign
supreme.
Where is she?
Okay.
Sometimes I don't know what arm I'm on.
Like, what arm is this?
Oh, of course she dodges it.
Oh my gosh, she's dodging everything!
There we
go!
Oh my god, there we go!
There you go.
I don't care your type advantage.
How is time to use against me?
I will win.
I told you.
I fucking told you.
It doesn't matter.
If I'm ice and she's fire.
I will.
Big boom always reign supreme.
If I'm grass and she's fire, I don't care.
I will kill her.
Big boom.
All right.
Tankboy Adventure.
They can only dodge so much.
I just got a boom harder.
Oh, Ash Ketchum.
will send in Charmander against Squirtle.
Charmander will reign supreme.
I don't care if they send out Gyarados.
I will send out Charizard.
As an infant, Dee was taken to Rubicon by her parents.
Because it looks so much cooler when Charizard wins.
tempted by the promise of riches from coral mine Pikachu
versus Onyx um Sons of making legal entry to the planet only
Dee survived the crash land she came under the guardianship
of Uncle Flatwood well of the Rubicon Liberation Front and
the coral in the AC was a young orphan's cradle and she grew
up to become a coral warrior well too bad she's dead now
too bad she's dead I wonder who killed her that aptitude
evaluation program number 24 rank e all right bye you weigh
you call sign little z ye commencing evaluation her history
doesn't matter when she's history all right kiddo oh at
least she dodged it good for her
Nope.
Oh.
Oh, she's lucky.
How is she living so alive?
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
I was like, oh, that's sick.
How are you still alive?
Holy shit.
You have more HP than I remember.
Alright, there you go.
Boop!
There you go.
Dude, I actually have more HP than I remember, girl.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Oh, wait.
I'm just in.
Oh!
Stop moving.
Yay.
Oh, she just...
God, she's like, fuck this.
You can't trust it.
And I did.
Goodbye, child.
Yay.
All right.
It's the tank.
It's the don't keep it.
Seven squad leader of the Vespers.
The Cubist group augmented human squad.
Swiss Burn is a product of Generation 7.
The first to receive experimental augmentation using Coral
Substitution Techno.
Jesus Christ.
Is that lobotomy emblem?
Oh my god.
That's hardcore.
Yeah, I was going to say.
That's a lobotomy logo.
aptitude yeah the sigil is actually just lobotomy and no
obvious indication of our efficiency or potential side
effects swiss burns fear and does turn into overpowering
paranoia the final jewel to crown his universe personality
jesus arena combat aptitude evaluation program number 23
ranking most normal pilot Subject AC.
Guidance.
Call sign.
V7, Swinburne.
Alright.
He seems like a well-adjusted human.
I realize I can just aim like this.
Oh, unless he...
Wait, that's illegal.
He's dodging me.
Can't dodge forever.
You also can't laugh.
Oh my god, he can!
Wait, he's hovering!
Oh my god.
That's actually very annoying.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I get stunned!
Bro, fuck you!
Okay, this guy's annoying.
He's just flying away.
Bro, this guy's just flying away!
Fight me!
Oh my god, we both stun each other.
This is so annoying.
We're just stunning.
That's actually so annoying.
Bro, yes, fight me!
Good!
There we go.
I don't care.
Nice, I did it.
There we go.
Jesus Christ, he just flies away!
You fucking fight me!
It was a mistake.
That's why I was like, good!
Get closer!
Fucking good!
Yay!
Yeah, we did Sunbaton.
And then Tokula.
Please understand.
He just looks a lot of us.
Yeah, if he didn't fucking take out his goddamn stick, he
could have won that.
I was like, finally!
I'm like, finally!
Oh my god!
Um, all right.
We'll do one more mission.
Infiltrate before you call it today.
Infiltrate Grid 086.
Wait, actually I can buy stuff.
Wait, actually, I bought- I forgot about this part.
I literally did this just for fun.
But I forgot it gives me...
I can buy shit.
I forgot about that.
I was like, oh, finally.
All right.
Anyway, back on the grind.
I just...
All right.
Okay.
What do we get, chat?
What do we get, dragons?
Is there anything?
Should we get more heals?
More heals?
Or should we get something else?
I killed.
Yeah, I killed for the love of the game.
I grabbed the pulse.
armor.
Unlocks core.
Pulse armor allows it to be installed.
Pulse armor creates a pulse barrier that trails dramatic
increasing until it exceeds its durability or timeline.
Do you have to... Okay, control R.
Like, quick activate.
Oh, my God.
Do control R for it?
Or quick turn?
Unlocks the quick turn line.
You see from a snap turns to side or rear direction.
Assault armor.
It's explosion centered on incoming firing cream damaging
area oh okay uh don't get assault is the get out of jail
free card
yeah i feel like turning me really hard on mouse and
keyboard
all right uh pulse armor is pretty popular how many times
can i use pulse armor anyway
three I don't even know what to get, guys.
Twice when it's maxed out, and our HP goes to zero.
Charges, changes per upgrade.
To be more tanky?
We'll do a pulse armor then.
Grab a tank.
Alright, we set five more.
What do we use our five?
Systems unlock?
That's all of them.
A core expansion.
Should we do our last one on heels?
Dragons.
Alright.
Last one on heels.
Do I need to equip Pulse Armor stuff or am I good?
Oh no.
I do need to equip it.
Thank God.
I think I double checked.
Just to be safe.
Alright.
Here's the request from Balaam Industries.
They want you to carry out an advanced survey of the central
ice field.
To confirm the information Walter brought to them about
the...
Girlfriend's talking to me.
Yeah, we're gonna get married.
Just stalked her.
Just met her today.
I'm gonna propose to her tomorrow, guys.
You could use it to launch your AC to the icefield.
Yeah, she's into me, guys.
She's so into me.
I'm going to ask her to move in in two hours.
And then tomorrow, I'm going to propose to her.
I think she's the one.
The lady in my head.
The voice in my head.
I'm going to marry her.
See, she's here to support you.
Be prepared for a perilous journey.
I'll be here to support you, Raven.
See?
She's here to support you.
me yeah she's in my I'm in her I have her algorithm yeah the
YouTube recommendations told me that she's so into me I'm
gonna she won't yeah my YouTube recommendations told me that
she's gonna Marry me guys.
She won't.
All right, look at me.
So beautiful.
Every time I look at the big job.
I'm so beautiful.
Oh
Every time every time
All right
That's right, I'm just gonna move on you know what fuck you.
I know I killed that kill him.
That's right Oh, shit
Oh my god, whoops.
Might be a little too tanky there.
I'm just heading over now.
Low and steady.
We're here!
Yeah, like I'm, that's literally what I'm doing?
Yes?
Oh my god, we both try to ram each other at the same time
Boom!
Oh my god, wait, wait a minute Alright, we've never mind now
I know we don't we should not ram each other at the same
time That might oh my god, it's him.
It's feet man.
I've heard all about you I've heard all about you feet man
All right, now I know.
Do not ram into peatman.
Might be a bad idea.
It's fine.
Let him mow the lawn a little bit.
His name is Dan Doki.
It's peatman.
Yay.
Don't worry.
I'll give you what you want from your diet.
clean breath.
There we go.
All right,
let's go.
Oh my god, let's go.
We're gonna, we're gonna be a Thruppa.
Oops.
That was, why did it not hit?
Oh my god, my missile is too big.
That was Carla, leader of our faction.
Whatever.
Fuck these guys, it don't matter.
Bringing with her a crew of junk wizards and hackers.
Within half a year, she seized total control and greatly
expanded their operations.
I don't get up there.
I'm just a little tank boy.
There we go.
Whoa!
Who's shooting me from above?
Boop!
was shooting me from above.
Arial.
Coming over!
Arial, I made it.
Hello.
These access?
Oh my god, what's that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, oh he's dead.
Wait, he's not dead?
He's still alive?
Okay, now he's dead.
All right.
I'll go.
Hello?
Oh, up here.
I'm here now.
Big boom.
Any other robots here to get boomed?
Boom!
That's right.
That's your first mistake.
Dead.
Alright, here we go.
Stood no chance.
I go up?
Oh, I go up.
There's hidden chests in this area?
Let's see, I can blow my way to the hidden chest.
Whoops!
Oh, what's that?
Oh, these guys.
Alright, nice.
Wait, is there anything down here?
Oh, there's hidden chests?
Hello?
I don't scan anything.
I guess not.
Oh, wait, there is.
Oh, it's all the way down there.
Oh.
I guess we'll never fight.
Oh, he's so...
unaware?
You'll never know.
Going to the pipe with fire?
There's a pipe with fire?
This one?
What do you mean?
Oh, this?
What the fuck?
There's so many things down there.
Oh, on the upper side.
Oh, this.
Oh, you mean the lava.
Oh.
Is this a hidden area?
Oh, it is.
Hello.
What are you?
You got gear?
All right, what I- wait, what did I get?
I don't even know what I got.
Go into an empty pipe.
An empty pipe here?
Now go inside a forge?
Would I get hurt?
Would it hurt me?
Oh, it doesn't.
Oh, this pipe?
Fire?
Oh, fire bat!
Wait, let's not do anything hasty.
I'm no one, okay?
I'm just a lowly depth collector.
I didn't know this was your turn.
I swear, the guy I'm after, he's a tricky one.
He could be hiding anywhere.
In the grid by now.
Wait, no, please!
You don't have to kill me!
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god, fire bat!
Fire, fire, fire bat!
Good thing in this one.
All right.
All right, down I go.
Is there anything here?
I might need to use another repair kit.
I got you now.
What do you mean?
I got you now, he says.
Okay, I actually might need to use another repair kit.
I know you're a damn thing.
You've made a big mistake coming here.
Oh shit!
Wait, he has a shield!
That's not fair!
Don't worry!
I put your money to good use!
Oh my god, he dodged.
Oh no, Zach!
There you go.
Oh, he couldn't even finish his cutscene.
Alright, goodbye.
That's the dead guy.
I got his...
Alright.
Hunted the bounty.
Boom!
Supremacy.
There we go.
I killed him so fast you couldn't even finish his dialogue.
Oh, nice.
Dead collected.
A little fucked up though, guys.
Hope there's no boss fight in front of me.
Hope there's no boss, but...
Oh, that'll be bad.
I wonder, when you die and you restart, does it count
towards your money?
How do I get back up?
Oh.
Okay.
Like, do I have to pay to be, like, revived?
Revived money?
Okay.
God, I'm so thick right now.
before take is getting out all right now i can go
all right it's like right here there you go feel like they
might throw me and throw another boss at me i have a feeling
oh maybe i should actually let me in case i feel like i'm
gonna fall your way to get up there.
I hope I make it.
Okay, I do.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
Hope I make it up there.
Alright.
That's good.
I made it.
That's a little worried.
Yeah, my generator is over here.
heating right now.
Oh my god, give me a sec.
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
Wee!
There we go.
All right, we're almost there.
All right.
Oh, does he see me?
Surely not.
all right we're ready to go oh it's this guy it's shield man
all right reload both guns
oh my god i'm trying to fly above you there we go boom all
right i made it
let me in
Let me in!
That's right.
You think you're a tank?
Let me show you a real tank.
You need to put more fans on this.
On my generator.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, hey.
Oh, my god!
Oh, this might be bad.
Guys, I think that's a real thing.
I...
Oh, I'm dead!
Who's the real thing?
Me, the real thing.
Talk smack it.
Oh, my God.
Was there a resupply?
I was just so...
I was just ready.
I was so ready to just fight.
I was like, I'm ready.
for you.
Oh my god!
What do I do?
And my dick wasn't built for this!
Yeah guys, this might be a real dick, not gonna lie.
okay I just have to be like flying when he she comes over
now that's a real take okay
I just have to fly over her when she starts blasting whoa oh
my god I was losing HP oh my god
Holy shit
All right Okay
Oh my god the fight Okay
Please He punched me!
It's so rough.
What do I just stand here?
No!
I got you one like me!
I got Jesus!
He's got me!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I forgot about the pulse armor.
I actually forgot about that existed.
I'm like, I just want to survive.
That's just my key.
Alright.
Survive!
Guys!
The pulse armor might not have done as much survivability as
I thought.
I don't know.
I thought I lived.
I don't know why I thought I lived.
I was like, nah, I live.
I did not.
Unfortunately.
Oh!
The 16 HP!
Look at that.
Me, the real tank.
Boom!
Told you.
You wanna go up top, right?
I'm the real tank.
This looks like a beauty blue cheese char to defeat the
cheese grater.
me thank you for the super chat thank you thank you wasn't
even worried see size doesn't matter guys oh my god 100 guys
it's not about the money i i wait spent it's about it's
about the end result guys i still won
i'm here for the love of the game.
I promise.
Let's go.
Booze.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's like aura over profits.
Oh, no new messages.
Why didn't one want to talk to me?
We've received a job from RAD's leader, Carla.
This could just be another one of her traps.
But after the impression you left on her last time, I think
it's likely let's take a look at the briefing there she is
what do you mean there's my wife all right we're gonna call
it here that was fun another good day good armored cord day
dragons great time had a great time playing it honestly it's
really fun game i love my build i love my big boom build i
don't know how it can than this i guess i can add bigger
booms you're right i could add bigger booms i can't well
we'll do that in the next stream and then we'll sell our
advertising space later uh oh yeah we need to buy a new
generator that's yeah you're right we do hey guys i'm gonna
call it here everybody thank you all for hanging out with me
as always uh tomorrow we have the my rival stream with dubie
i'm not sure if she's streaming um she said uh she just say
like she said like um the reason why i picked time her
internet will be fixed so we'll hope that if her internet is
fixed she'll stream if it's not she'll just hang out with me
um anyway guys thank you all for watching i've been having a
really fun time with armor cart as always everybody stay
hydrated post-check get up and move around get that blood
flowing and if you step for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye big boom big boom